all right and we are live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast episode number 62 and
it's another glorious Sunday we are back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day and
happy matriarch day all the moms out
there in the round we salute you all
we've got Walmart Leakes and Sony III
plans Nintendo switch online plans
destiny to war mind phasing out base
consoles Microsoft quadruple a studio
and days go discussed we go get right
into it let's introduce the four
horsemen and no usual suspects at the
round table
my co-host with the cold most my brother
from another mother the difficult game
Conqueror and the half of the young wolf
mommy
Lord addict how you doing sir doing
pretty good thanks a room for coming up
yeah I like that and of course we had
our most technical gaming Lord the solo
gamer who lives for the single player
selfish experience and also the sastra
Davis mr. offline profile Illuminati
himself mommy no its sovereign how you
doing sir I'm doing all right
you even be in this band I appreciate
you but you already know that say thanks
for coming through on this glorious
Mother's Day and of course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this the Lord of
combat sports was a man of his
convictions the man's
nothing less than the premium experience
and is to get money gamer Oh beloved
Lord King how you doing sir I'm the
front I am so happy for what transpired
last night to HBO
we're trying to make a star if you just
lean into trying to make a start with
Jorge Linares versus Vasily lomachenko
but this is the fresh this is the one
that they telling you it's supposed to
be heir apparent to anything for money
Mayweather has everybody
yes this guy is supposed to be the bee's
knees of this it's supposed to be the
second coming mm-hmm
how you gonna be the second coming oh
yeah they'll go and introduce on
yesterday but these stilts oh my god
he's the matrix he's to make his skills
is unparalleled listen you have T type
of promoters right you have the promoter
that's like Eddie snake oil salesman
Herms you will go get somebody and build
them up and feed him steady constant
food of garbage right and Bob Arum fits
in that same mold Bob Arum is looma
chuckles a manager or promoter he also
promotes Manny Pacquiao now what they
would do is take a guy invest let's say
50 million dollars into one guy right
and in that 50 million dollars they pay
him more than they paid the other
fighters in there that's in their stable
and then feed him those fighters as they
get older they already have a name and
they feed him that person and they know
if this person had an injury when it was
training or whatever and you all know
this stuff but that person will go
around beating
dudes oh my god dude build him the
hottest latest butters then you also
have a promoter or manager like
Mayweather's promoter and manager um you
know let's say ellaby let's let's split
let's put ellaby there right now and
then what they do is they get a whole
stable of guys and they pay everybody
equally and it's like Barton camp and
it's like oh hey steel sharpens steel ok
right so in that kind of camp everybody
gets paid at least 2 million dollars or
whatever and may the best man win
yeah and going through you actually see
come competition and these people
actually grow and so you see um Shawn
Porter versus Adrien Broner
you see these top fights and then you
can actually get a basis of how good
fighter is by him fighting still
sharpening still and even if they do
take a loss you understand that they
fought the best and getting that loss
right ok so you can feel comfortable in
your guy if your guy actually runs
through a squad of hot dudes now we have
a 70 loan with chinko last night
and he went up against Jorge of Gothel
Linares you know gato ray sovereign they
call this man the cat because he's so
agile on his feet and he is so nice with
his hands right but he's under power
this is his nuts he's underpowered and
maybe his face might give out on him too
many shots and his face give out right
so they put oh the silly la mode the
matrix uh-huh
Chango in there well gato and oh god
those handling dude
first I gave him the first
well I gave a second round I gave him a
six round and I gave him the ninth round
you got knocked out in the 10th round
but in the sixth round the silly Lomo
arms oh hi chinko got caught with a
straight right here to put him down on
his butt oh wow that let me know one
thing if you ain't it with a real dude
yes you in there with a real dude he's
gonna put you away with that one shot to
the face it was a clean shot to the face
don't be fooled by what y'all saw that's
HBO crap going at it again
I just wanted y'all to understand it was
a good fight but how they set up
fighters and if you feel good about your
fighter you gotta know that he can get
in there with anyone in the world at any
time can't feel good about that guy that
guy yeah we had said I was that was
definitely up for HBO stinko not the
preview did you catch any UFC I didn't
catch it live but I did see a little bit
this morning I saw never in my life what
I think that a fighter would get caught
in his career yes with the same
appreciate this one I know the combat
sports that they don't wear these days
but Lauren added you would appreciate
this because we grew up the Anderson
Silva Fame right so know that his famous
knock out one of his famous knockouts is
the front kick to Beto belphins face the
cover
did it make the cover of a UFC game
how you doing sir
hey what's going on guys absolutely UFC
last night oh yeah that to that card
we're talking about the Vitor Belfort
Leo told me cheetah car yeah you know I
saw that you know lyoto machida or I
should say Vitor Belfort hasn't learned
anything how crazy is that to get
knocked out with the same style front
kick the same positioning technique have
you not evolved that is the problem when
you have the geriatric league I just you
know look you know you get to a certain
age and you know it's time to hang up
the gloves
and you know for Vitor you know he's
never been the same since he's been off
TRT you know max thank you thank you I
was just about to go to a lot of these
dudes relied heavily on you know
steroids and stuff back in the day and
now that the you know ufc's cracking
down on that some of these guys in
hanging
yeah it's facts I mean it extended
careers and let's be real like a Vito I
had a run you know during the trt phase
but for his age because I mean Vito's
been around a long time
I remember Vito the Phenom when it was
called him a phenom and he was like
Tyson back in the day right and this kid
just stormed he's been around a long
time and just to see like I said he had
that downside then he kind of had this
crazy upswing during TRT era and
everybody was like come on oh yeah man
that guy had muscles upon muscles
the tiger uppercut thing you got these
two older dudes that you know they're
both on an even keel here and you think
it's gonna be a better fight and maybe a
better outcome for Vitor here because
let's face it you know Liotta hasn't
been the same either you know but with
that that cake was so fast man I guess
it was faster than the front kick that
Silva through yeah yes we missing one
point like I have reverence for him so
he so this was the Brazilian showcase
gonna see him just show that restraint
and then just bow to him like like
respect me felt like he killed the
legend these guys have to fight these
geriatric leagues this is what I've been
talking about for a long time these
boxes don't have any UFC fighters combat
sports in general don't have managers
they like go into a community college
right and they don't have the financial
advisors and stuff like that for people
to advise them to save their money to
invest in these properties to do this to
do this smart way and set up a 401k plan
for when this is over because this is
going to be over what we saw last night
was the exclamation point on somebody's
career from the fights from the face
last night cuz I got one from Bellator I
want to finish up yours ooh yeah
did you guys talk about the the rest of
the card we have not and the Nunez yeah
and here's the thing about Amanda Nunez
that's nice to me it seemed like kind of
an off night for her but yes
she didn't look as good as a sharpest
she wants it usually does and I think
Pennington just had no business in there
to begin with he basically went to the
corner and said no mas her corner should
have listened there's a big controversy
right now in it she came out that last
round and her corner she went to her
corner says no I'm done and they were
like come on go back out there and it is
a big point of contention left for now
where are you at with that because this
I'm seeing some of the community saying
like hey you have to listen to the
fighter if I doesn't want to go anymore
you throw the towel and then I'm hearing
the fighters saying hey I would want my
corner like we should take like I don't
want my corner to do that to get me out
there to give it that last whatever
what's your feeling on that whole thing
not far as a corner man okay here's the
thing I think this fight is gonna be the
fight that signifies basically that that
puts it out there that maybe the fighter
should be listened to a bit more because
what happened when she went back out
there already she has she knew it was
shattered she was in a lot of pain but
the amount of blood that came out after
but anyway I just think that she knew
she knew she was done and push her out
there like that especially up against
Nunez come on like penny again she had
no business in there going back to
Amanda Nunez like having an off night in
the beginning like she traded blows with
her and it seemed like at the very least
you would be able to stand with Nunez
which really know what he can do at the
beginning at the beginning and then it
towards the end that the last couple of
rounds those perfect entre knees those
combinations Nunez was putting on her it
was over it was you saw the the writing
on the wall I just you know
and she said you know I knew watching
the fight um I loved Amanda Nunez I'm
sorry
and what y'all saw when they was
training in the beginning like y'all
probably thought it was something even
what I didn't see that I saw a give
ground and when I seen give ground I say
okay this is going to be the tempo of
the fight and then it just started out
as okay you said even then she gave
ground and then she come in and she keep
giving ground when you give ground
mentally you're breaking down when she
went out corner and told them you I'm
done it's a wrap it should be something
in place that the fighter can say well
they've done it in boxing you know No
Mas I'm yeah there's a rap right here
I'm not gonna I don't care what these
dudes is talking about um and it would
say to a face from explosion no it was
so scary that to seed that much blood
and I'm not gonna say just because it's
a female but it's female fighting um we
are protective by Nature over females it
doesn't matter that's how it is and to
see her face explode that much and then
to hear her say Pryor y'all I don't want
to go back out there
she said head shots her face exploded
and that would have never happened had a
corner cared a little bit more eyes I
knew she wasn't in it and mentally won't
you check out you check out she's done
her mind wasn't there no matter what
like she went out there and tried to go
through the motions but she was mentally
done like there was no all she wanted to
do was defend herself and find a way out
of here the problem is you have Amanda
Nunez coming into this fight she was
twenty four and six and you and
Pennington was nine and five and the
last time she fought was 2016 why was
this girl there that is my whole point
to this like it makes no sense and I
don't know what transpired there but
what made the UFC say hey Penningtons
next in line yeah I think honestly
because of what you call things fell
through because they were try to get a
sidewalk fight with her
right and I think for whatever reason I
don't know you know that that fell
through or whatever but that's let's be
wrong real real like that's the fight
you want to see right by these other
fighters sometimes not capable of being
in that same ring wif that other fighter
and detrimental things like this happen
yeah
so let's move on um we had also on the
card we had was we had Alphonse we had a
Jacare Souza the old guard I mean Calvin
put on a good show dropped him and
believed in a second and yeah I mean yet
a pretty strong performance you talking
about now that he's gonna hold out until
he gets a title shot would he feel about
that funds um I think he's deserving of
a title shot he's he's been fighting for
a little while now a few years and he's
he's got some good names under his belt
and I think that this fight against
Jacare was a good test because honestly
once Jacquerie usually gets people down
on the ground man like is great
Cerreta he had Calvin on the ground and
I thought man for him but he pushed
through and got the win on this and
there's the thing it could have went
either way for me and and I'm glad the
judges got it right with a split yes
yeah because it was very very close it
was close it was I agree
and last but not least I want to comment
on Bellator I don't I'm watching I know
me and there was a particular fight that
stood out to me and as we know there's
the heavyweight totally going over there
the riot Vader and the kickball of all
that with 50 seconds a goodness it
little king it felt like if Avery a
dream grown up went up and wait and
tried to get it all with a heavyweight
Varro in 15 seconds he got his wigs like
it was the quickest hook and dropping
and he was literally asleep like I don't
know it was so bad because I think 50:50
was like at Bellator he pretty been
doing a lot of stuff promoting with
Bellator and yeah man so basically I
don't know where they were fighting what
Indian casino was this ad it has a lot
to do with it because again we gotta go
back to the steroid thing Bellator is
all about that stuff you know this is
why he tried to get a fight when
red-faced GI heard the rumors rampage
and I don't know what's going on I just
know him a coger is doing some business
but it was funny because literally when
Mol got knocked out 50:23 that he's like
Dan Nader has been around for a while
you know when he was at the UFC he
wasn't looking this good you know he
needs that juice so he's King mo King mo
himself I used to like King mo a lot
he's a good dude met him one time it's
funny I got a funny funny story about
meeting this guy me and my best friend
met him at one of these conventions and
this guy man he liked us so much he just
gave us his phone number bro like he was
his phone number back in the day if you
were talking to him and you liked him or
whatever he'd say here use my phone
number text me whatever wow it's like
that's crazy that's I got it credit mean
no he would give it out so much that
after a while his you know his his
management team told me you gotta slow
down a good fighter he said I don't know
man I think his chin just got ready he's
not a heavyweight
he's never been heavyweight grandpa's
before has he he was not with these
dudes
new Strikeforce or something right it
was strike you will see got a hold of
Strikeforce fighters they could now wait
to put them in the ring with the only
people to do well other Strikeforce was
like Ronda Rousey for a while Ben
Henderson came from the WWE that's right
accurately acquisition but you have seed
that had some stars some legit stars out
of the Dare no we still have cowboy
Cerrone to this day we've got you know
Ben Henderson man we've got so many
people that came out of there that were
great great fighters WC is one of my
all-time favorite leagues man absolutely
they always put on a good fight good
bunch of cards last night you know
combats what's taking about the tea of
God to chat weekends in the business of
combats what's had to go down yeah then
you may watch that Loman chenko fight i
watch that what did you think of that
because I've been saying that bar
baram's been profitable he's gonna put
them in there with Manny Pacquiao many
times catch a resurgence
as many pack jackets still crack he'll
crack you in your head and split your
dough straight down the middle
I kind of see that I kind of see that
but at the same time you know there's
glimpses of Manny Pacquiao I see in low
in shape but is he as good as Manny in
his prime now I don't know so we got for
Congress boys don't want to get a
question or not shout to the Lord Victor
Alice Tina chat he says he definitely
wants us to do a question and answer
segment maybe at the end we can do that
but I'm gonna actually give him a favor
since he he was dealing with the combat
talk he's basically it's asking question
concerning halo do you think 343 I needs
a new leader
other than the Bonnie Ross I like her
but I finish taking halo in the wrong
direction perhaps she needs a new studio
with a new light Pete what do you think
about that Lord Fox talking about halo
and what now and Bonnie Ross
yeah like basically um they saying that
343 needs kind of like a new a new
leader so I think I honestly I think
that halo needs a reboot completely you
know I think though that the route that
they took took it with Halo 5 because
I'm playing through the halo 5 campaign
again I don't ask me why I'm putting
myself through that [ __ ] okay but I'm
doing it again because I'm trying to
give it sort of a second go through on
the X as well because I know what man I
just keep thinking to myself as I'm
playing through it man this game just
needs a reboot um cuz you say here's one
of the things about Halo that I think
that needs to be reworked I think the
guns need to be all reworked man because
about this game that feels so stale
these same guns we've been playing with
these same guns for ever oh I think
that's the one thing we really love
about destiny is always having these
even when the reskin they're doing
different things do something different
with these weapons gotcha
friend of sovereign attic Danny any
feeling about Bonnie in halos direction
like they need a reboot I wouldn't mind
a third person action game in the Halo
universe with Master Chief like you know
you know I said it before Master Chief
he's like a seven-foot-tall like
cyborgs like here you know let's do some
more stuff with him other than just
shoot and be able to like to run fast
and jump high so attic what have you
been playing man let's get into what the
Lord's been playing when it comes to
this whole hey look people put jumping
people put dashing and in in sprinting
into well the halo of the Spartan - and
sprinting in Halo and look what the the
outcry was a community Hey look like the
people who play destiny the people play
Halo both of them are they played that
both games but they're completely two
different player base hmm if you'd be
switching up making a third party like
look people might play it but you're
gonna have half the fan base is like I
ain't messing with this it's not halo
you got the other half of the fan base
it's gonna be like well I guess it's
okay but you know I'm probably not gonna
pick up a sequel look they're taking
Halo in the right direction they just
messed up on the story okay so that's
what happens if six is a dud you can't
deeming the story is the hope a
multiplayer is still one of the highest
played games on xbox dad you really
you're not tired of any of those guns
man people like you just mentioned
destiny to say people say this is the
same people got the same three guns they
go into every multiplayer map or maybe
Laura Lee is right when he says that
maybe he was a little bit more variety
when it comes to guns in the main
campaign I feel exactly the story is the
only thing that needs to be overhaul
they need to make minor tweaks to the to
the multiplayer and bring it to the next
game and they need to completely they
pretty much need a fire whoever made
that a Halo 5 story
yes it's the word was bad I mean like
you know I work at a job they tell me
when they're training me to talk to
people was like keep expectations a
realistic level they went out there
saying this is what you're gonna get and
I understand why they did it they did it
to hide the fact that Cortana is what
[ __ ] crazy on public or Tana went
crazy but at the end of the day there's
better ways to hide that fact and
blatantly lie to your player base so you
say the trailer guy messed up a nest and
that's the thing about his all-star
playing the game the port honest stuff
doesn't even get shown to you in an
interesting way like you know she's
going crazy
and you know no he's gonna have to make
this one of the they did in the game
right Cortana shown up in the Earth's
solar system sitting there she's like oh
I found you she takes off I see that's
why I can't that's like one of my best
halos besides you like fighting the same
boss that has to do with the story I
said
how they need to go into this is they
need in the second because I people want
want to redo not want to find out what
happens to Cortana I don't care but can
we kill off lock right at the beginning
in six they need to go towards that halo
2 direction or lock is a second
character and he's not the primary focus
they really tried to do something but
they did a wrong yeah they did not
fulfilled what they try what they did
yeah yeah let's take out a war for
instance they're introducing it's a tree
of whatever his kids name they're
building the fan base to love this
little kid they say they let you fight
with them in the second one he's gonna
be older in the third one he's probably
gonna take Kratos to spot like they did
give one we probably gotta kill them
like it okay this is how I like okay you
get into the first one God Awards
letting you build up to and if they go
that would they can go that way cuz they
built people up to like the character
sure people are still gonna be mad but
you can't keep the door open to throw a
grenade and kill Master Chief in the
same motion no I like that's literally
what they did yeah I wasn't a fan I mean
at the end of the day like that was a
little bit over the Havel the
multiplayer is fantastic still you know
I do be reforms that they do need to you
know start popping up this far the
variety with the gunplay and stuff like
that and that's why you know we still
what is the low destiny for that fact
that gunplay
but um yeah it's just at the story
that's my main did that's the end of the
day the story needs to be reworked there
needs to be more of a character
development you can't have a talking
scene a whole chapter there was a whole
I enjoyed the gunplay hey hundred Bungie
said you can have these guns but we're
taking these with us what I think that
is when they messed up on the
Prometheans from Halo 4 they could have
did so much more that race yeah their
intro messed them up from the starts
they couldn't do nothing about so
finally playing Halo I had to keep them
playing which was nicely I have a couple
games I'm playing right now I can't
really go into I'm playing I'm actually
playing a game called a master of anima
that's like really fun cool yeah what is
it full I only know it's on the Xbox I'm
not quite sure if it's on the switch it
looks like a switch game that you would
play so kind of like an echo just well
no it's like it's like a strategy
turn-based like what happens the world's
being took over because you can actually
shape-shift stuff into people and like
your sensei's old disciple comes back
because they everyone thought he was
dead and he just starts shape-shifting
like the most bad stuff in the entire
world cuz he's got like some uber powers
now and he's like summoning giant golems
and stuff and like you're like a
disciple and your girl was like a
prodigy she disappears because he knew
she can't feed in those lands give me
that again one more time that's sound
pretty cool it's called master of anima
it's a really fun game like it like you
can at the beginning you could only
summon like soldiers but now I'm able to
summon soldiers and archers and you have
to like wertham together to make us like
together individually they're useless
but like you you keep this the archers
in the back the soldiers in the front
the soldiers were pretty much be meat
shows for the arches to attack like and
I've only unlocked - so like 6
yo what are you nothing man I wanted to
play some war and I play Nathan the only
thing I play was a little more just want
to throw that out there mean kid beat
that the same day came out pretty much
but you also be got a war like I don't
know how many days your name is attic
for a reason okay three coming I
couldn't wait for destiny to come out
and when it came out I felt like a
newborn baby back at it but also at the
same time een shoutout to you to your
pod shots that I've been actively
flashpoint baby you know I was actively
inside the flash points and I said I
can't write anything inside I wanted I
wanted to troll buckets and I just I'm a
super fan and I'm one of the five fans
in corner but y'all stuff that I didn't
know what was going on and we're gonna
talk about that later but on pub G did
some crap they put back out demur mom at
the same grade that daddy came out and I
was going back and forth with death and
with monkey playing destiny as in Chris
and then sliding back into pub G I was I
was a man torn I was a man living a
double life
[Laughter]
I see I see death in the chat
aka Blizzard be take any song we danced
in this I know that's your crew no doubt
no doubt shout out to bring harmony in
the chat new new new person in my life I
lost podcast brother that's what it is
I'm here for me it's just been on it's a
lot of love today that like if you think
he looks like you got to show your face
so they know that you look like oh I've
already heard it all look like boy I
look like started the leviathan Wiens
law dad ignore lad know about that doing
a lot of crucible you'll shout out to
sinister shout out this super gangster
he's getting apartment in the with the
we tried this raid I'm sorry I got tell
a story in the raid we were in goes that
uh the taken King we're in the Dagon
raid or was it chrono is in crota we
just quote him and we tried you know all
you got to do is shoot your gallon ones
at the end right like shoot him take him
down and we go on it I swear we is
probably there for four hours when we
beat him he what
because no data can tell you to debris
version of it but it's just like yeah
Lord I wasn't pleased with the teamwork
because the Leviathan way requires a lot
of communication a lot of teamwork felt
good but it seems like that side on the
solar side whether addict and super
gangster wasn't going so well huh he
wasn't doing little stuff they needed to
do like calling out what colors is on
his part or like that's important do you
expect me to go run around buying these
little crystals or wherever there are go
over there tell them your job and then
go do my job and then go do kognito his
job when he's doing synthesis job and
they go back to do just a gangster's job
again first no I got too much to do and
I can't come back just to tell you what
crystals is on your side like like you
wouldn't go to elementary school you
ain't cold wine you know this the raids
bringing people together once again yes
last point I want to make is on with
with the whole rate thing is shout out
to Xbox lfg because because of Xbox
allergy we have got some of the funniest
elitist random people in our six when we
are missing six people if shout out did
he do who was 360 light who came into
our chests so that we were 340 like with
attic vent house light level it
immediately left the chat usually me but
not that time so let's get it to even
rambling long enough alright last week's
poll results are in and the people have
spoken to the question when negative
impressions or preview coverage of a
highly anticipated title or released to
the public
ahead of its launch date how much does
this impact your decision in buying the
game the winner at 41% in a razor close
4-way ILP poll was the it
has no impact if I love a game I will
still buy it group coming in at second
though super close
38% was the only if I'm on the fence
about the game group shallow third place
that 16% was you just scared of that
Metacritic fam covered it at last place
it was a huge impact won't buy the game
what do lowered Fonzarelli think about
this man you know usually for me it has
a little bit of impact on my buying
decision when I see when I compile a
bunch of different reviews especially
from maybe sites and people that I know
personally you know if they talk
negatively on something and give me
their explanations and it makes sense to
me and it resonates with me than I then
yeah it may impact my buying decision
but for the most part I like to try the
games myself before you know hopefully
if there's demos or whatnot but yeah you
know usually though I know if I'm gonna
like a game you know before it comes out
fax fax I hate loss off real quick want
your feedback on this same way I usually
I've done it less recently but I would
usually pre-order in games if I know
something that I want
I rather I like to read reviews and
stuff and people's opinions on the stuff
after I've played it and kind of see
what where people's opinions of the game
by how they buy with mine and how they
are they different but you know I want
experience it for myself for me every
now and again you're gonna find like
you're excited for something and it
turns out to be a dud and then maybe you
have a little bit of a buyer's remorse
but after that now I rather plate myself
yeah a close one I mean obviously was
raised close between the people who feel
you know that if they love it they're
gonna buy it and also the people that
feel that hey you know if I'm on the
fence and I think I'm kind of
combination of both I think if I'm on
the fence with something and I do hear
like say something I'm like and I'm not
sure I had lukewarm interest and I start
to hear a bunch of negative stuff from
people I trust at reviewers
then that may say okay I'll hold out for
the sale but if it's something like I
love for example you know this is kind
of low-key inspired by the state of
decay Fiasco like I'm gonna get it
that's how like I told people and
alphonse me and you've had this
discussion online like you know they
literally can give me stated k1 reskin
now what stills gonna be today when
that's how much I love the original
franchise so ya know I started playing
state of decay again you know last week
just to get back familiar with the
controls again and then they irrelevant
native shout-out to enemies in the chat
last night he's like man I'm addicted to
it again and I said exactly I mean it's
just that good if you're into these type
of survival games this one is top-notch
man yeah absolutely so you'll get it to
these topics and I got a lot to talk
about on anyone else I wanna pour Fargo
you know actually really what really
helps me make my decision is my tight
group so if I notice like a lot to do to
my group is going to get a certain game
and it has a multiplayer function
because most of the games that I play
and mainly I gave them on Xbox there's a
multiplayer component that's linked to
those games that allows me to know that
okay
I'm going to be able to enjoy this with
set amount of friends and no one will be
excluded now single-player games like
I've been trying to get right back into
God of War but these multiplayer games
have been yanking me from that
experience so no matter how great a game
will be scored or how many our ha bad a
game will be scored doesn't skew my view
I'm gonna get it because I want it
because I want to experience it but also
me pre purchasing the game really has a
lot to do with my community know I
figure a that's actually a great point
as well tap it so we don't get this
thing going Lord sarcs Walmart in the
news Sony it was going over
all right so let's start off let's have
a round of applause for Walmart
[Applause]
one job one job about this time some
online wing of a brick-and-mortar store
or an online store finds it in their
heart to fold III for everyone alike up
to the plate and did they ever had
basically every game coming down the
pipeline III and beyond in some cases
get into our talking about their
everyday is Nietzsche ox day go so the
big one that's been talked about and
this list is rage to from but
and it's software um it's kind of a
surprise cuz a lot of people figured
that rage the first one didn't sell as
well as they had hoped so maybe he
wasn't getting a sequel but I mean
Bethesda shown in the last few years
that they're willing to take risks on
properties that they own and bring them
back out
yeah right you know it is which is-
that's we made two stacks on skyrim we
can afford some walls they may stacks on
so um rage 2 I believe tomorrow we're
probably gonna get an actual actual
reveal from Bethesda themselves about
rage 2 so that turned out to probably be
true Wow and then looking at the other
stuff on this list Splinter Cell which
has which is kind of been hinted at but
still you know has it has actual
announcement so they folded that for
ubisoft the division 2 it was already
mentioned that um last of us to sony
already mentioned that they were gonna
focus on and we'll talk about that the
second part of this talk gonna focus on
specific games so we knew about that so
leslie other stuff that hasn't been
announced just calls for buy avalanche
the original Just Cause 3 came out years
ago now it makes sense uh that game I
think people were excited for Just Cause
3 because Just Cause 2 kind of blew up
because of how crazy of a murder
simulator it was and implement something
and just cause for that makes me want to
finish that game oh yeah they're not
gonna give you a story that's for sure
you're not getting anything that they're
gonna give you something it's fun to do
in the world to blow stuff up and that's
about it
the first one came on when it came out
on xbox was kind of broken and janky
they fixed it some more and it runs a
lot better on the X
but no X enhancement for that game it
needs the next enhancement to the core
it runs hard it is broken but I love
that uh the wingsuit the wingsuit is hot
either place what is destiny comet
that's always codename for the expansion
that they will always launch on the Sony
stage so it'll basically be the taken
King equivalent for destiny whatever
this year in September and that's coming
that's a fact that's that can't be hard
to guess that's definitely ok so the
things that they talk about let's see
let's look at this Dragon Quest 2 that's
that was assumed that was it was coming
NBA 2k obviously Metroid Prime we're
probably gonna see something we're
probably I don't know about a game
played with definitely a trailer on
Borderlands three had been hinted at
again they have all but not announced it
yet so this is all stuff that's coming
down the pipeline y'all good and evil -
we just saw another tech demo mm-hmm
Final Fantasy 7 remake we talked about
this last week on whether it is then we
go to Lego DC villains I can see that
happening I mean again you know Final
Fantasy 7 that is coming but not till
the year 2028 will be put up a sass ins
Creed which I think they said there's no
Assassin's Creed this year if they're
gonna be doing Splinter Cell and they
I'm hearing watchdogs I don't think I
think they realize it's a little too
soon watchdog
how long is put women part to come out
get rid of those trendy hipsters and I'm
all in is is the basis you know the base
element to this game the hack is the
yo-yo not so cool main protagonist was
like a barista at Starbucks enhancement
world was really no X enhancements for
that game okay
now winding down to the children to be
the Xbox released is the kind of Numa hi
so give the war five and that's a little
surprising to me just because there's no
he said he's hitting awaits
bouncing awaits and visiting mom's grave
have a great day all must love recipes
to your mom happy matriarch they always
appreciate you to channel a spoon thank
you so much
continue some so yeah gears five gears
five is uh it's a little interesting to
see there maybe we'll see some sort of
some sort of trailer or something story
something a little bit of a teaser yeah
you never know if there's some sort of
spin-off as well we heard that uh the
coalition was working on some other side
stuff that it kind of shot down but you
know maybe it's just to throw people off
but it's interesting to see it before
halo and maybe it is interesting that is
interested they just have halo really on
the wraps you know shout the Lord Santo
but know that it ended in the building
said gears fire me happening he said
gears is for farming so it could be like
the knee
conventions could be wrong maybe there's
some type of spin-off title it would be
interesting it's like yourself if it's
before halo rising like kart racers the
last one on the list is towards the
horizon 5 which is obviously a misprint
cuz it yes so this I made asset
guarantee we're gonna see horizon for
this year on that the same release
gating so risings yeah I love horizon 3
if speculation about Japan is true that
seems like a great place to take that
game and expand on on the festival stuff
that they've been doing the cars the
night scenes should be crazy
armed with this one being from built
from the ground up for the X is it's
guaranteed to be a beautiful game so
excited about this stuff man so the
funny thing is Walmart after all this
happened they say well um so they didn't
run it back or anything like that they
didn't specifically say they were like
oh you know these are just like spit
speculation on our part
this is speculative on our we're gonna
do anything to run it back it's it's out
there I don't pages available anymore
they might have cleared the page out but
so yeah that I didn't hear anything on I
want to let this wash over you because
you will get that Dragon Age because I
want that as well don't paint none
listen of mine and yeah and ran down
Thor has been on the show
that room is beautiful with a minute
it's fantastic yeah absolutely so the
Lord Ram might be seeing him soon back
don't worry about it um yeah this is
interesting I mean we saw this before
I mean I'll jump in real quick it's not
a true is not that it's that it's just
like common sense so I don't think they
they're like you know so out there they
just got a lot of typos you know the
gears five-to-four horizon fine
shoutout to disney chair he said it's
fine because they know snappy glove I'm
done the other day I don't think this is
too far off I think there's some truth
and I thought what was interesting is
how but says the reacted to the rage to
leak did you even pay attention it
almost felt like day that was their
contingency plan because they knew
something was gonna leak or it was
planned and they just ready to do this
because yeah because they complain with
it on a social media page I don't know
if you guys have seen it vast majorities
is when I feel this common sense and
stuff we knew what
let's get addict in on this what do you
feel about the Walmart League the
Walmart League
yeah true natural time and saying I mean
I think 100% is true yeah the only thing
I think people get place orders confused
yes yeah just because Final Fantasies on
there does not mean it's not gonna get
put in December of 31st 2018 mmm the
majority of these games are going to be
like that of every game you think of is
all Walmart this that doesn't even
released a mm-hm
you can pre you could pre-order so many
games at Walmart you go over there right
now you could probably find a listing
for Final Fantasy 7 you know they put
that on there to to build height that it
not even really bill hype to to let
customers know that they are selling
that product this is a question I have
like I and this would probably be best
suited for like Matt piscatella somebody
who understands like the
retail pipeline how early do these
publishers and these companies have to
tell these retailers about that these
leaks come out so early like do you
really have to allocate shelf space that
early like they did this so everyone's
talking about Walmart this wasn't an
accident
this is a publicity stunt that Walmart's
one of those people that they walk
around and they like I say anything I
want what you gonna do not let me sell
your game take it away from them so
that's like games talk like games talk
you know they're in that industry so
they have to be more professional games
true in everyone's world mmm but they
have to be more professional because
they deal with these people on the
regular mmm like it like actually talk
to important people not just the
marketing person okay I need this and I
need this many of this like Walmart it's
like yo I could stomp on you like so you
got to potentially like just because
they can literally come out and say this
is coming out this day this is coming at
this day they might get sued it there in
any kind of NDA
but at the end of the day regardless how
many people sue Walmart they're not
gonna be like yo you can't sell my
product because they need to get that
money back I mean relationship needs to
be intact you know so let's see so um
yeah that's what I got is for the
reversal of that what about the second
half year you point a Louis on Sony
announced how they were gonna handle
their e3 press conference it's
interesting cuz Shawn Layden said that
in in lieu of their regular like
announcements where they just gonna come
on stage and announce brand new stuff
that people want expecting they're gonna
focus their press conference on four big
games that they have coming up mmm which
are ghosts of Tsushima mm-hmm Last of Us
part two spider-man and death stranding
so now this kind of brought the ire of
people because obviously you know
fanboys on both sides start talking
about what that means
hope they don't pull out their IKEA
furniture no no that's cool I got really
jumped on Twitter man is like it wasn't
even that bad till kid Smith retweeted
it then oh my god they were crazy if
people sitting there like I read you
some of the tweets people sitting there
obviously I can't read them all because
this is I hope you know what here's the
thing like people sitting there and I
hate that I can't bring up anything
about micro about Sony we'll have a
Microsoft throne Angela yeah it happens
consistently every time I know it's
console war stuff but I know people that
claim that they not in that console war
stuff that be doing it too so here for
instance I said III for Sony looking
disappointing actually you know what no
I can't share the screen but III Sony
looking disappointing hope they have
surprises man because and to me that is
what III is about it's that surprise
factor it's that showing whatever you
have [ __ ] and like look like I get
that people are like I understand I
completely hundreds and agree they've
done enough to where they could date
they have bought them enough buy time to
not have gained tip but they always
announce stuff that comes out three
years from now when so are so right now
yeah here's some of the stuff I had okay
Nintendo had III just Rizzo to Microsoft
last year only announced one new game or
two and the rest were indie parties I
think Sony gets a pass after hear after
this first party output this generation
I can agree that to a point income I
used to say that what Xbox would
probably show cracked
for the third time at e3 since 2014 once
again like I said bring up Xbox in its
consistent you're like from PlayStation
perspective it's sure disappointing but
the exact same blind up was on Xbox it
would be second coming once again
brought up Xbox like I feel like some of
these people literally can't argue
without bringing up another entity to
argue with I'm disappointed I'm not
saying that like you know I had nothing
to do with the Xbox thing I was just
like yo I don't want to sit here and see
four games talked about for an hour and
a half
all right now let me ask you this laddie
because this is definitely a very good
point you're making and a very big point
of contention you know obviously we know
Sony has been dominating the gen let's
just keep it a buck and they have the
first party thing so you know they seem
to be taking a different approach right
they seem to be saying it's gonna be
more of a deep dive with these four so
the four let's reiterate are gonna be
that's trending spider-man goes to
Tsushima and the Last of Us - then
they're saying that there was definitely
not gonna be no new hardware shown right
so just want to clarify right so no
notnot ps5 honest why look at it from
like a perspective of stuff that they've
done what next year they're going to
they're gonna announce these four games
next year people can say what they want
go through Kashima and J's dawn there's
a good chance those games come back to
ether he get next year okay probably
gonna get announced the release date
coming out to be a days gone on isn't in
that four four so who knows I know game
former has a month of coverage and me an
addict we saw that okay yeah mm-hmm so I
mean they've made improvements but what
you feel like
who you think that nobody got a chance
to touch with oh no controller was
involved in that controller and of a
show of hands here who thinks that
they're gonna show blast of us again
next year I don't see last of us coming
out to fall next year I don't say coming
out to play so far
Bopha III think these four games first
of all I just want to say that I think
it's brilliant that they let the cat out
of the bag early because if this is all
they show then they don't have those
high expectations from you know hey you
know what would help
I think they're gonna have a surprise I
listened to Shawn Layden on that
blogcast and he basically he said that
look these are the four games we're
gonna go in-depth on for first party but
we're still gonna talk about third party
and we're still gonna have our Indies
and we're gonna have some announcements
he said so sometimes you don't know what
those announcements are right they're
gonna announce how much the PlayStation
so do we know that's gonna be it me you
know what these four titles along with
it well with three I'm very excited for
um des training I'm still like what the
hell is going on you know I wrote baby I
don't I don't know what's going I got a
curious take on it to I think it's very
interesting I think the realization is
that whatever else knew they they have
in the pipeline are gonna be PS five
titles and they're not ready to talk
about those just yet bingo bingo do deep
dives on the games in nor coming some of
these I think it will be cross-gen games
at least two of them um and we're
getting in September so it's kind of
weird that they put that as a deep dive
as I know yeah I figured it'd be on the
show floor but have a deep dive during
the
quote-unquote conference of forward I
don't know I would figure that days gone
would be there instead so that's a
little weird to me but beyond that yeah
I mean again they're just gonna hold
stuff close to their chest until they're
ready to talk about that next hardware
and that's just it
nothing let's get lower King on this he
had new hardware like anybody else and I
love with new hardware D buted on the
stage it was I kind of looking forward
in a weird morbid way of Stoney pushing
out a PlayStation 5 on top of the next
to the people that just brought a pro
hells today yes I know I could buy it
and I know it won't affect me if they
just push the pro to the side and tell
you here's the five we are here now so
but I want to see the little games I
want that stuff I want that excitement I
love the excitement with a new system
but the fact that they not showing it it
underscores exactly what they have in
the treasure trove maybe they do have a
so calm for that next system maybe they
do have those games that we want for
next system will this this e3 be
lackluster form I don't really think so
honestly I think they're gonna show
those games in a way because trust me
when I tell you that presentation is
always King off the charts show those
games in a way and they're gonna set it
up in a manner that's gonna make you
walk away they could show three games
for this show might still win the show
yeah am I the only one that feels like
if you don't like that you know that
last of us feeling like God war feels
like the exception because of the
brutality and that the character persona
beside behind god of war but if you
don't really like that way they make you
know the Last of Us and on charges like
do you guys really think it's fair point
that like Sony's just okay like we're
gonna make this kind of game over and
over again like if you think about it
like big like budget atados they make
that's all they've done they've never
went out
I think the problem is that they're
proven successful at dominating a lane
that supposedly is not supposed to be
profitable anymore right that that
single player cinematic story camera
angle experience right that something
that you may look at it and say hey you
know what it looks kind of similar to
some of the past titles and I get that
but what's the success of God war and
Last of Us there's Dave they have no
inclination to stop that that's a lane
that they're winning they're diming and
that's solely this now I will agree with
you an Instamatic I do feel that listen
i think III is one of the greatest you
know spectacle right you get there you
get excited you want to know what the
company's gonna show and to kind of know
everything ahead of time not everything
but the majority of what they're gonna
show ahead of time there's a little
disappointed me sometimes because you
want that surprise that wonder you know
you always wait like Laura solve knows
like you wait to the end the show and by
the way you love those moments right so
they to hear that okay this is gonna be
a no hardware I'm gonna have a third
party guys come on hurt just the inner
wonder in me cuz I kind of like that
aspect is that your fans talking about
but but but here's the thing I love that
on to that but no for doing this podcast
iron Lords now and you meeting a lot
more people within industry and
everything and then some people who know
people that know people you start get
leaks and stuff all the time so really
it does kind of suck but at the same
time it's like give me that info give me
that anything no no listen I wish you
only I get it you know said way it's
funny you brought that up you read my
blog cuz that's gonna be the four
questions later the whole thing is I get
that you completely right well far as
I'm with you on that that's gonna happen
all I'm saying is I've never seen the
company say yo this is what we doing you
gonna get this this and this and you're
like even like you know worried about no
new hardware like - like wow
you know that's that Sony swagger right
there you know we got like it or not
anyone like Bluff onsen anyone's in
positioning no it is them I mean they
have the cards in your favor the sales
are in their favor they're dominating
the single-player genre you know you
know a lot Lord Acton Amin that may not
agree with certain things the way
they're handling this but I mean listen
at the end of the day we can't act like
those games are not quality games either
those are solid games we know they're
making stuff but people attack me
because I said well you know til I call
all their Studios are making stuff would
what more do you expect I'm like these
are the same people who flipped out on
Microsoft because all their studios and
they were making new games like is it
wrong for me to like just want to be
surprised at e3 me with you that's how I
like being surprised I agree with the e3
thing like III that's what it is that's
that wonder especially for guys you know
going over there to hour and a half on
one of the most iconic stages in the
industry do that all PSX don't I hear
you addict but I think at the same time
I think this does it this shows you that
this is the end of this generation yes
please like I said you know by 2020
you're gonna get that PS 5 and people
that are saying 20 21 20 22 you guys are
delusional I'm even thinking November
2019 I really think it could mean even
put a nightly narrative if it's not a
generational like super generational
leap if it if it is a backwards
compatible machine and I think yeah they
get away with with fall 2019 because
it's not this thing where it's like it
creates enough distance between that and
the pro
that people shouldn't feel shy stood not
I'll be I just feel there is such a
commanding position there's no ninety
above it is like thanks people out there
that are saying they're gonna feel
shafted if they bring it up before 25
[Laughter]
well we're gonna start getting now is
we're gonna get start getting these
consoles coming out no more true
generational consoles it's going to be
upgrades because they're always gonna be
backwards compatible you know to a
certain degree to the one previous to it
and I think the pro in the ex will still
be able to play some of these games that
come out initially on the theater you
get into our later topic the previous
generation that can only be with Sony
because Microsoft has shown you that
they're going through their whole
catalog of games released over since the
og systems so I believe and this is just
my opinion of it being a Microsoft
already I said that president is going
forward I don't believe it actually Sony
does back at all no no I I think I think
the ps4 games will be backwards
compatible it will strictly be those ps2
ps3 titles that they're doling out now I
mean well they are just knack yeah yeah
but but honestly I think at the end we
can go away it's it's hurting bad man we
need to know we need to get information
on philosophy wise its system they don't
believe in that they actually told you
nobody plays that our analytics say
nobody goes back
we only gonna go forward and if you want
to play that they got that guy that that
tells you if you want to play our stuff
their old stuff is the thing we gotta
call PlayStation now right now so I just
want to revisit it when it come because
I have no expectations for them to do
that okay with that piece now what is
that running at 720p on those ps4 yeah
yeah and that isn't gonna do it for
people with these 4k TVs and stuff
that's gonna look like crap when you're
putting the PS 5 games I mean I
sometimes try and get into these older
games some of them are great I can play
through dead space and some franchises
that are just excellent but when you try
that new game that that came out in on
the 360 that you've never played before
and it just made I can't get into it
like it just you know having the stars
running behind you don't play those old
games doesn't do BC back there done
he said he just Marathon bad burnout
revenge it's nice to play games from
every gen and own them digitally not
streamed and locked to the play games
supposedly functionally mentally view
saying it's not supposed to work but
they're working 90 something million
sold apparently they don't care I think
it would be a mistake for them to do it
but at the same time I think they could
still get away with it because what they
will do they'll change the narrative and
be like well you know our thing is brand
new you can't no turn around say well
you can't run those ps4 games on this
cuz this is something totally different
when people will buy into that market
but xav say it's x86 though you hate but
we know that right the other sixty
million people that buy Playstations
don't care about that about PS now
either obvious
we sell you all of that stuff they need
to check it does like shellfish so I can
see them going both ways I think it
would be a mistake for them not to do it
but I could see them totally not doing
PlayStation now and playstation again
represents that he's like hey he doesn't
play all games maybe wanted to he has no
interest going back by respect to
Microsoft make him available so he's
kind of that contingent if they don't do
it you know bothers look games like Red
Dead look at that game came out and it
was out selling new games like it might
not be a big thing to me but people that
say it has no relevance whatsoever
they're delusional
ah but addict but here's the difference
you had that Red Dead come out and it's
got that polished that glossy
yes you got that PS now and it's 720p -
I'm talking about sold everything not
when they did that patch later ok ok
it's still great that's compatible it
was like 7th on on the chart like a 10
year old gang yeah because you can't get
that game on anything else to look any
better than it does I mean look at
perspectives like if game stop is
raising prizes on 360 games they
consider relevant hmm its interests this
is an interesting is gonna be very easy
to see what happens it's different
philosophies let's see if they actually
change that and if they actually have
the capability to implement it in the
manner that Microsoft definitely
structured their own infrastructure
around bringing your library for that's
been their mo that's what we got Louis
are you good ones good on that a ps3 I'm
up grandpa did
go back in the headlines again switch oh
I don't think we can go one podcast
without talking about out to everybody
in the chat man lots of people there hit
that like button if you will thank you
so much
so graph on the time they reveal the
details of the highly anticipated that's
which online so basically quick first
can I can I respond first after yes you
I'll give you the first is gonna give
you access to the online multiplayer
free NES game support offline and a
dedicated mobile app as well as the
ability to save your data to the cloud
something that Nintendo has not been
offering so we got some one three price
points we got the one month for the four
hours three months for the eight and
twelve months for the $20 so you there's
also a family membership option then
allows you to turn the switch up to
eight switches for about $35 we don't
have a specific date
we know that the app is still in effect
it's going to be used for in-game chat
with other players just like the t2 and
the launch lineup of those nes games
that included our ice climber the
original Legend of Zelda Mario Brothers
the trilogy Donkey Kong and so on so on
that's what we know right now as of
right now they've also made a statement
on Virtual Console the intern though has
confirmed that they do not plan to bring
virtual
primer I'm done let's break it down for
the final thing again you know Don when
the online goes live certain features
will be locked behind the paywall these
include the online mode and of course
the the tender switch online mobile app
what will remain free of charge will be
the eShop managing your friends without
messaging scaring screenshots
to social media which parent to control
and free software updates so Lord this
day has arrived a whole year deados our
last service announcement it's $20
anyone that same ain't gonna buy it's a
bunch of lies okay so um look if I want
to play Super Smash Brothers I'm gonna
pay $20 you guys be acting like you
don't go to McDonald's to spend $20 the
features were wack yeah with a view of
the cost that the services calls for if
you want that that that product that
like Microsoft or Sony got then you got
paid $60 a year if not go go to the poor
man's game and get the $20 ones did you
just pull up me now call your friends
call a friend get him in get him a dick
his pulled of me I want you to
understand he just went so premium on
you he just went to the dollar sign on
yes he just finished telling you you
spent 20 hours at McDonald's I wanna
hear that crap he just told you
everything about this your pockets are
looking funny
it is all today this is this is the
topic
sorry addict and stepping on your toes
I'm going to back out I'm going to bring
up the rare on this one has spoken and
surprised us III can I'm shocked
anxious watching I'm loving this I got
you but I want to get it to solve
I'd be solve right then I'd need because
this is this is for us this is awesome
we were gonna get abused I need to speak
to my switch brethren I got agree with
$20 like we already knew is gonna be $20
right and the funny thing is that even
like the family plan makes it even more
appealing like like two and change for
first it's like like 250 per person is
like that like you know whatever it is
for $20 listen I'll go to the ends of
the earth with them for $20 who cares I
will not I will sit here we'll talk
about it we'll analyze it but I can't be
mad at them mad I can't be mad at them I
cannot I'm shocked now that what it does
also though it gives them leeway to
increase the price as they add service
right give him that leeway and still say
they're cheaper than everybody else so
do that or not I have no idea but it
does if them that that room to maneuver
and do that stuff you know did this does
the fact that the the cloud stuff is
behind a paywall
and everyone else's is free it's it's
$20 that given is that Microsoft cloud
not be IFA is it would be probably is
right Kazuya is down with them could be
a Zuri Zuri running around in the back
of the listen yeah whatever it is I'm
not fat without all these cables and
about this before we give it to LA Kings
gonna anchor this because we know this
is Lord bloody I know shout out to the
saltiest the crew smash the crew or is
good he see and glad to have you in the
realm on Mother's Day which is good now
my question obviously you've heard about
the Nintendo online service
I've heard what are your feelings on
onset announcement well I have mixed
feelings about it and and I've come out
on this because we actually recently
talked about this over with the GOG crew
so yeah so what happened was my thing
was while the online is a good thing for
them getting set up and trying to to
bring this over to the switch and try to
get that online infrastructure the fact
that they're doubling down on the on the
app they don't have any sort of
dedication with the switch makes it hard
to use that's the worst thing and and
with the app a lot of people are saying
that one it's already bad because the
fact that it's a battery killer for your
phone because the fact that it
consistently drains really quickly and
it constantly locks so it only adds more
issues well the price being you know as
everyone's been putting it as a cheap
price that's great and all but the
features that are coming with it while
some of them are useful the big thing
that a lot of people have an issue with
is the gripe of the online cloud stays
and I stated that what the online cloud
says well this is being added as a
premium feature with the paid
subscription it shouldn't be because the
fact that one you already got to think
that the switch already has a as a
designated amount of space and storage
on it that's already low and you have to
think that physical games take a large
amount of that storage then with adding
SD cards and then being as cheap as they
are being able to expand that's still
another physical aspect that has to stay
that data so if anything happens to that
SD card and everything gets corrupted
you're [ __ ] out of luck you have to pay
for cloud saves while not being taken
almost saves don't take up a large
amount of data the fact that you have to
pay to get those cloud stays behind a
paywall or black it is it is and you got
to think that with with with switch it's
in a unique spot because you think cloud
saves are already eat whether you're
gold or not is already given for Xbox
because the fact that they have the
internal hard drives and it's saved
there as well as it has a backup cloud
safe should anything happen to your
physical it reverts to a previous cloud
state the PlayStation has
works a little bit differently though
ders is also part of their pay PSN the
way that thirst works is they have one
more control over their cloud sites
because they can manually backup any
physical saves on the console to the
cloud and should they ever not an excuse
hang on I see that it's a unique spot
because of all you have a little bit
more yeah I'm not saying it's better I'm
just saying it's in a different spot
compared to what exactly but the fact is
that for for for Nintendo having to pay
for these cloud saves is the issue is
one of the big issues while while the
price is fair for the year with twenty
dollars for a single person on what was
it thirty or forty four four four seven
four seven that's not a bad at all
that's not that's not that price for the
fact is how much did they state that was
going to be for the cloud saved out of
that it's gonna be much is that fair
between the family using seven people or
even if it's something like 32 gigs
depending on how many games are coming
it's it's gonna go through well it's
gonna go by account individual accounts
it's not gonna go by like one share file
like it said on there for up to seven
other accounts right but but that's the
thing is they say up to you seven other
accounts but they didn't clarify because
if you think about how this which
already works even though you have
separate accounts it is all still say to
the same shared device as well same
shared SD card they haven't clarified
how you haven't clarified in that that
information is not come out your own
knows exactly with that I hate you now
my question you'll all bloody I know you
miss some great points my question to
you though is in reference to the cloud
stays because we know prior to this you
know there was no mention of it and we
know a lot of people are switch owners
who were clamoring to Nintendo please
please please give us Kyle says please
give us got a lot of people have Britt
their systems you know a lot of people
were actually surprised that that it
actually actually are gonna support
their service and have this service not
a lot of people also surprised that this
is behind a paywall
you know they got the razor blade their
systems
don't break so in that respect do you at
least respect that they got the actual
feet
or that doesn't impress you no it's it's
a good thing that they got the feature
it really is because it shows that they
are trying to to make it more appealing
as well as to be able to take care of in
there trying to make the 21st century to
the 21st century but I know like what
well yeah well like but Nintendo's
always been very iffy with their with
their online services and this this kind
of goes not just beyond Nintendo this is
most Japanese companies with their
online is that they're very nuanced in
the way that they that they use their
online Cisco's it's still very archaic
well yeah Dragon Ball Z online as well
as look at Monster Hunter online
I mean Nintendo still using friend codes
and those are are more ridiculous than a
lot of Facebook integration buddies yeah
they're trying to stuff it up man I know
they are trying stepanova I'm just
saying that there that if you look at
them they're they're very nuanced in the
way that they have their online set up
for a lot of the nuances of how their
online structure that's a way of telling
you I'm gonna tell you what they tell
you very patient so you're coming to
chat you about to kill this topic is Flo
Joe's killer
all right I got that look man I got that
ice climber warmed up as well and you
might as well show me your phone number
too because you're gonna need that to
chat okay so is this what are we paying
for like the same stuff we've been using
for years Nintendo
what is this $20 for cuz you ain't got
party chat you ain't got regular you got
friend codes still like what are we
doing in hey are you gonna go ahead if
you had a switch would you buy Super
Smash Brothers if I had a switch in the
household my son would be playing Super
Smash Brothers you lying cuz you'd buy
in one it went but here's the thing
here's the thing what am i what are we
paying for though like why you pay for
your kids happiness
he's been playing on that 2d s for a
while and he plays with friends online
and stuff and I'm just saying to myself
what is the difference now what are you
giving us for twenty dollars a year the
same damn services they've been giving
you which has been no fan to be like a
lot of this stuff is just verbage is the
way they say it too because okay so
playstation or xbox xbox doesn't
specifically say that any of this stuff
is included in your Xbox Live
scription obviously that goes to a lot
of different things it covers like the
the cloud saving stuff isn't free they
just don't tell you where the money's
coming from they don't tell you but
somewhere in that money that you give
them monthly to access xbox live you're
paying for that right so Nintendo just
stupidly decided to tell you yeah you're
specifically getting this because of
this they could have very easily charge
you 20 bucks not mention that and you
think it was free can you know what I
noticed too and this goes for all
podcasts this is not just iron Lords
call for any time Nintendo is brought up
I see those numbers dip on the
viewercount he comes back up
particularly worse because this is
always me incognito fighting it up
fighting the good fight and then you
have these two unite but he also good
question though he says do you think
that if you lose your subscription this
is further proof that this which is a
handheld people and not a console that's
having this chat they're not having
headsets they're not doing any of that
that regular consoles have period this
thing and that's why the switch is doing
is because it is a handheld everybody I
know that it
tells me you have this many systems that
they dropped out they dropped out all
those little mini systems I got it and I
knew you wasn't getting Virtual Console
cuz they're making a ton of money or for
those little V consoles so now that we
ain't getting that we get an ice climber
deluxe know what they gonna do keep the
same graphics add a buddy adding online
buddy
through app now check this out you see
what I got right here I've been waiting
for this to use this to show you this is
what you need to add to your phone right
um so that you can um play on a thing
you have this to add to that because the
power your phone is gonna go down and
make sure you don't have a limit on your
data cap
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
they want you to bring it up you got a
[Applause]
[Music]
phone call to Nintendo that one guy hey
I can't afford to build this month
because a please I'll get you this the
best way and how any further than what
they was doing and I told him they are
going to completely whip on this they're
gonna hit the head with the bat it's
like a very boss something to the plate
and he threw the pitch and he swung he
missed and hit himself with the bat you
know what I'm sick and tired of every
week been putting out the old weak
educated turds and shining them up
talking about your check out this new
turf it ain't new is the same
alternative smell the same old way give
me new games give me new games with new
functionalities and please get it up to
the 20th century for essentially this
system of the palm this system is so
below the board I'm glad they acted
I'm glad that they can
oh yeah I mean the whole thing is the
price point cool that's nice I mean we
kind of had the riding on without out to
Nick Tendo sauciest gamer dad gray
podcast talking about the subject and
it's disappointing there's there's no
getting around it at the end of the day
controls very disappointing you know the
price point is good but it's just
disappointing for the services we waited
a whole year to not have messaging and
voice chat and to still be locked behind
that stupid Aten unacceptable
don't like that aspect and it's far as
arm just the flexibility of not having
an app and only thing I'm hoping on and
we'll get this into next week so I'll
get into my theories on what's going on
is
there is an alternative method one ya
know who is buying this whack this
online to play Super Smash Brothers
after buy I have no choice but at the
end of the day you know it's very
disappointed I said we waited that
length of time and you know this is what
we got and it's just it's just an
antiquated thing in this date they
refuse it's like collecting sand it's
like them hitting them all their own
self but their own bat in the face
they're winning and there's no reason
for this and that's the part that's
disheartening so that's all I got a
little father's ready for us to leave
Lord addict a certain DLC has job war
mine came out it was kind of
disappointing but I feel like it was a
good direction in the right direction
that destiny needs to go so I want to
bring it to the to the table and I speak
with the Lords about it do you think it
was it was enough to keep people to go
to the expansion in September or do you
think that they might have lost because
they didn't have a really good out into
the next one alright so let's started
off with who's actually played the TOC
first anybody in the panel has played
I'm assuming Fonzarelli know I'm a
looming bloody no that's correct I was
watching my roommate played okay look in
your hands up look like I said I
listened to your flash points and use
y'all going into the nuances of the game
and what to expect in a patch notes and
stuff like that so I was pretty much
abreast to it and when
jump back it's what I've been away from
him for so long that it felt new and
fresh but immediately isn't playing the
game um like lor Fonzarelli was saying
he didn't like really the guns that were
available inside halo and the guns that
are available in this game and reworked
of exotics and stuff like that it really
shines through they know if they don't
know story if their story is so small
and you don't really have a real giant
law outside of the book so outside of
the grimoires and stuff like that they
do no gameplay they do no aesthetics the
the way the world looks the way the
enemies move they know that and what
they do they do it well and jumping back
in I love how the exotic spells I love
the masterworks of it because Lord Chris
um actually he's the heart or game way I
was taught I was calling him Lord
adderall in the beginning he really
plays destiny he's really enthusiastic I
gauge how the community sees the game by
the team that that that's inside to chat
with us and these guys are losing their
mind with the new lighting on certain
parts of the boards of the new strikes
the enemies the very they can't change
it too much fundamentally but they can
fix some of the things that were broken
that people was complaining about the
game is faster the game plays a little
bit more solidly of the exotics feel
like exotics there's more hardcore stuff
to do if you weren't at a certain level
you wasn't finishing a strike so to be
honest with you they did what you guys
complain about what we complained about
they tried to fix it as best as possible
and I see it and I told them I said you
know a lot of people are complaining
that oh this is right here it didn't
feel like much listen the first pay for
a deal sees that you pay for in that
package are really small bites right
right and the big one is the one that
they're gonna announce later and that's
gonna come and ask
be like a taking King type of thing and
that's the one that's gonna have a lot
of change into it and that's the one
that's gonna assure you into going into
destiny three so this one felt very
substantial it felt like a step in the
right direction when I be back in the
rage yes I kind of felt FOMO right now
will you was talking about Lord sinister
and y'all was in there and or since it
did ask me sure that's a little sinister
you did ask me did I want to help up
give my light level level right but I
was going to bed you know I work at
night so um III definitely wanted to be
there and I felt FOMO because I'm like
man they had so much fun in the rain I
want to know what it looks like and I
want to know these things
so am i excited to play yes it's pub
Jeep pulling up my legs yes it is but at
the same time I got a squad that's over
there and I can't deny the fact that
they took a step in the right direction
I did not feel buyer's remorse like
anybody else let me ask you a quick
question before I pass it off now what
do you say Lord King to the people who
will say I know bloody and fans got
their guns ready what do you say to the
people say look you know that
disappointed with the game since launch
I felt you know cheated robbed or
whatever and at the end of the day that
they shouldn't have to wait to you know
for this game to improve after all the
mistakes of Destiny one and also with
the fact that let's be honest in
September we're gonna have to pay for
even if all those changes do happen
right and it's the game that we want
ultimately in destiny to and it's it's
that in that taking King style expansion
what do you feel to the people say hey
but you're gonna have to pay for that
and I'm not willing to do that and
they're finessing your finesse and it's
like what do you say to that contingent
[Music]
brings your face so the fact of the
matter is if you felt that she was
entitled to anything you are entitled to
nothing if you don't choose to purchase
it do not purchase it I will be
purchasing that sir I do believe in
destiny I do believe in what they
promising your promise thing that
they're going to try hard they promise
anything I listen to the community
and they're gonna push forward because
they are trying they're gonna fold up
day ten and it's gonna set the hell with
you guys we made our bread made a lot of
Redmond 2017 it was a lot of bread they
are giving you what you asked for
I'm sorry I can't walk away from from
this after playing with a couple of my
friends I can't walk away from this
saying that I fell with this DLC because
I actually like this DLC a posthole
Cyrus
I thought Osiris was a little flashy I
just had more substance less flash fair
enough I want to get the guests in on
this we know I know I had fawns on last
night with a on a brat Ram we had a good
one on this but I won't also want to get
bloody cuz buddies he going hard man
podcast and these appearances on such as
gaming podcast so bloody what's your
feeling of what you've seen no more mine
what's your impression of destiny right
now where you have this hope okay from
what I think I do understand where kids
hey they did do a much better
understanding of the story however while
they do have an idea of a better
direction it shouldn't be this long I'm
gonna point out this as as caught me to
point it out the first time with destiny
one came out it was something unique it
had a lot of flaws but it had potential
and we saw that growth over three years
but each time we had to pay for an
expansion to see those improvements
destiny to was the definition of an inch
deep in a mile wide alignments to the
gameplay were what we wanted the content
was not there it was not substantial
enough there was no reason to grind or
anything else the raid wall cool had
very little afterwards because of the
fact that if you had the cleanse they
made it very very casual friendly
because they made it so you don't have
to do anything you can get free stuff
we're having other people don't know
that takes away from the aspect of doing
it as well as was
already solidifying and making
everything set perks the casual way from
the looking for the gun that you want to
get with the right perks that you want
for that weapon and took away a lot of
the aspects that people chase there was
nothing there
curse of Osiris was the first expansion
that was what 15 $20 at the time and it
didn't add much it just was a little bit
of a story that completely fell off with
one of the biggest characters and the
Lord because of the fact that Osiris had
so much build-up for four years how
important he was and we saw him for what
all of two minutes was minute and
nothing but these memories are flashes
over Cyrus or whatever the hell he was
called and then saw him once for five
seconds at the end to talk to oku Cora
and then left that's it we don't see him
at the tower we don't see anything else
he's he's gone then you see fast
it wasn't an MPC and if you wanted this
the go show of Sagara you had to go
through microtransactions to be a go
show you didn't get anything for doing
the content the weapons themselves that
were a part of the lighthouse were
heavily grinded that were nothing but
risk ins with just some added wires to
make it look vexing very nothing and now
we come again for it talk about come
again now four or five months later with
what they did right now with warmind
one that that some people don't like the
name because the fact that you look at
all the others very cool names dark
below the rise of iron you had there
taken King House of wolves
you had cursed Osiris and then you have
a single word at expansion with war mine
a lot of people wanted to be gods of
Mars because that made it so much more
concerning on what tied in to the Lord
now with that they brought in the fact
that one this is another DLC that just
used reskin enemies beginning but they
keep bringing the goddamn hi back is no
bloody is a cool concept why the [ __ ] do
we have to go to seven expansions with
the same goddamn enemy in every single
one because the hive are always there
just like the the fall
and every expansion even if it's not
about them are still goddamn there why
don't they do anything you saw what they
did with the taken which were just the
same enemies with just made black and
white GUI and they haven't changed
anything the fact is - and I brought up
what we're seeing right now with war
mine and what we saw with cursor Osiris
was meant to be a part of the game five
years ago wait originally was written
they cut it up and put it on the shelf
for nearly five years this is five year
old the reason I'm mad is because I
enjoyed destiny I did I stuck up through
it through vanilla through here one when
it was the darkest days and all the
improvements in taking King and then saw
wind rise of iron came out it was in the
perfect spot right amount of content
right amount of rich enough to grind
where it kept you going great what we
got in destiny - was such a major step
down I'm not going to do another three
years of iteration to get it back to
where it should have been the first few
and then add the content look at the
Rays that they've added there's small
short raid layer layers one main tactic
is not a failure the fact that yes I get
it's a trilogy all explaining about
Calais in the Leviathan the lore about
Calais is great I have the I have the
collectors edition talking about that
why is the fact that everything has to
go back there if it doesn't necessarily
have an aspect to the convention each
like each before had their own dedicated
rate yeah any sense to this to their
story that talk bloody let's go because
of the fact that look at look at Oryx
and look at crota that all tied to the
to the this expansion that I came sorry
whoever whoever came out with raid there
is to take over layers they need to get
fire yes and you're telling me in a
studio of over 900 cuz they're it's 300
at Bungie and they're using three
separate studios to work
on this you're telling me during the two
years because they had OOTS they had to
push back destiny to because when
destiny to launch that was actually
supposed to be their next expansion
because rise of iron was supposed to be
supposed to be there's only after taking
was supposed to be rise of iron to fill
in that time gap before destiny to came
out when rise of iron actually launched
but because of the fact that they had to
do another reset mmm like they did with
the first game in it ax ask Activision
to let them take another year to do it
that's why we got such a soft content
launch with when they're bringing back
the was it the the the wave mode there
in the in which yeah in there right
after taking King and we had those six
months that were buried light up until
rise of iron correct and rise of iron
had a massive content drop whoa what
happened the darkness crazy but Vegas
and and this is what what's the most one
not only that is that the fact that they
took out the darkness because they had
no idea what it was is the fact that
they have shown with these two
expansions that they are not capable of
putting out enough content in a short
period of time without picking just risk
ins and using already made areas they
made they made two small areas that they
can make use they they kept talking
highly talking about the infinite force
it more society seemed this big
procedurally generated area that oh yeah
and you use it twice in the story you
and you can't use it after the story it
would have been it would have been as
well as the fact that they the only time
they use it
is on certain patrols and then they
stated that they have these really hard
patrols that are gonna be there in the
court aboard you know mercury and it was
completely on worth the time that you
put into it
mmm-hmm no you preaching right now
that they've shown that while they have
an idea and and that they repeat that
they're listening but they keep making
the goddamn same mistakes over and over
and over again right and where you're
right little buddy in it the first one
sent you you drop bombs straight fire
and where you're right is because at
this point how can they ask the
community to forgive them after the
mistake suggesting well like you said
when they had the game in a state
towards the end by you figure taking
Kings last rise of iron from a reward
standpoint from a grind standpoint from
a time investment standpoint things and
systems were in place that made the game
worth it and to have destiny to launch
in such an aggressive casual state it's
like it's like I said when the you can
ask Laura Carney to the moment they get
him launched and I played like two days
of it I was like you know all the stuff
missile for destiny one they're going to
make a big deal when they bring it back
into destiny to like like its new like
it has it that Street talking about
public matches you did the same thing
last year yeah look and here and here's
the best part about that is when they
did their their spring roadmap when they
talked back in April and they said look
guys private matches coming back 6v6
coming back it's like what the hell were
you thinking that's what we had
originally I understand the forties
before making things tactical but it
slows down no it was back tickle at all
bro that 4v4 was trash basically it was
just because the fact that they made the
maps too large to fit for before they
were made for 66 the only way that for
measles mattered wasn't trials because
it helped out too even with the three
VIII's on some of the maps but as for
everything else it did not do anything
as well as with them already increasing
the ttk and making to weapons that were
dominant enough to to bypass that and
hit hard enough and kill that made the
pvp useful here's the thing bloody you
you've talked so much you've basically
you know put out there like almost every
single problem
they're with you no destiny - III can
only add a couple of things here like I
don't know if this stuff has been
changed because I stopped playing a few
months back but I will say it really
bothered me was who told them in the
first place that we wanted the the
weapon slots changed from a primary
secondary and heavy slot I know nobody
right and then you know when they took
away the fact that we had legendary
drops with different roles and they took
that away so the grind wasn't there
anymore that's one of the things that
really pissed me off
because we always looked for that God
role and that was one of the top reasons
why I used to love the place right yes
they totally made strikes irrelevant in
destiny - for me as they did and also
they also took away the ability the
simple ability to choose the strike you
want to play yes yes yes ridiculous
stuff like that made me walk away
especially with the fact that as the set
rules because the fact that all the
newer weapons just being grease cans of
guns that we already have or having some
of the same set rules they're just very
cosmetically different and you look at
what happened with destiny one with each
of the expansions their guns were
different because they match the
aesthetics of their of the the expansion
that came from but they also had
different perks look at him look at
vision of confluence the gods here scout
rifle of vault of glass they may look at
Bank of air youth from the extra from
Chronos raid and that was a faster
firing and it had full auto it had it
was significantly it wasn't even about
the raid guns though it was about the
Kreg weapons like the grasp of Malik you
know yeah and the strike destroy glue
they made as has been very lackluster
and here's the worst like I get that
they reworked the exotics the exotic
guns good step the the changes that they
made have helped to improve those
weapons however the fact that now they
made ornaments you have to um you have
to first earn the ornament then you have
to go through these long processes of
trying to unlock them by doing some sort
of long grinding tasks
makes no sense when you should have you
already brinded to just get it as well
as the fact that the masterwork a system
that they haven't placed it doesn't do
much all right the exact mass work stuff
is actually not true
because what it is the mass works do
give you a tremendous game player
benefit which is one
it creates orb creation with multi kills
then you also get armor resistance based
on the subclass and you configure
ability with the actual stat so say for
example it armor piece has recovery or
mobility you can actually configure it
with the masterwork I'm not saying that
these are oh my god game change I'm not
trying to say that but I will say
offensively if you have in a masterwork
that's why I like having a legendary
master was a huge advantage because if I
had my better Devils master work of my
name was midnight and I'm getting motor
kills I'm generating off to create super
nice he creates more offense which is
one of the problems like horn one second
that was with the next Destiny to
vanilla the cooldowns were so slow
getting you grenades and your supers
were so slow
everything was neutered almost to cater
to a PvP crowd for the snake exactly and
that's what destiny is about Destin's
about that power fantasy feeling like a
guardian getting your super doing things
and they they were so hell-bent on
casual izing things and making it easier
to get difficult things removing the
grind and then also that separation from
PvE to PvP right and it was still there
with with going after this master work
stuff right but this master work stuff
to me it wasn't as satisfying I agree
that Nicholas granted Graham in the in
the chat here saying God roles meant
they would have to balance more which is
they didn't want to do for PvP and he's
right but at the same time we have this
one issue with master works so I mean
you know there's always gonna be
balancing issues and that's the one
thing about mmm opposed that you can
never really fix between PvE and PvP I
said always Hillary his ass but I'm
gonna make on it and I'll give
like I know you want to talk yeah the
thing is they've they come into the
destiny to write this seems to be a
conscious decision that we made because
destiny one is and I had this
conversation with Kyle box before we
have to admit as fun as destiny one was
right it was me wasn't the most balanced
PvP so to speak so in my opinion they
looked at okay let's try to balance it
let's try to get into the eSports scene
you know and all of this at the
sacrifice of the hardcore base and the
sacrifice of fun was more fun the chase
for the random rolls weapon placement
all those things that we loved there was
no they have the formal there was no
need to change it so that why we went
after those weapons because we've acts
have those God roles you know [ __ ] VP
and you're not part of the chase part of
the fun in the in that game and destiny
one so I mean for me like people who are
complaining about these God rules and
stuff you know what get good go out
there and go out that way but now with
as you mentioned what the PvP because
they casualized it they're literally
there especially when I was playing back
in September and October there were two
auto rifles that were in the and the
energy weapon slot now as I put it that
were literally the top tier as long as
you had one of those you didn't need
anything else there was nothing else to
go if you wanted to use anything else
you did that in PvE you go specifically
into PvP use one of these two auto
rifles and I think once i machine them
that was a kinetic I think it was the an
Co of D you use those with with just
just very very bare minimum of aspects
and you're set because the fact that
they had the hot the the fastest ttk
they were the or decay ting and the fact
that most of them had increased the
flinch so ages
you were just random everyone had to say
in loadout in a discouraged weapon
variety exactly it was there was no
weapon variety and and and some of the
weapons that they neutered if you looked
at how how the what was it uh exotic
scout rifle I can't think of it right
now Ida
yeah the Mitel worked at destiny one has
had very fast firing had flinch they
took away the flinch ingesting the
firing so now it didn't have that same
kind of aspect
it wasn't used very much in PvP because
the fact that it didn't have that
defense against something that were I
had those added flinch the in the worst
thing about is when you mentioned the
subclasses is that they took away the
variety mode outlook from the subclass
on braaap and that that was a huge
disservice because you basically
simplified the mid maxing the
customization you you now just basically
have to preset Priebe a loadouts per
subclass and you're locked in you have
you can make no combination of a skill
and here's the best part about that
because of the fact that they simplified
the loadouts for four subclasses is that
one of them for most subclasses are very
irrelevant from some of the perks that
are on this so people only use one the
entire time so you're not mixing it up
you're not making variety you're not
allow your sex to do it like I always
play it as a hunter and when they
introduced in the taken king the Night
Stalker it had really good abilities it
had where you can shade step it also had
the ability to where you have the
increased radar and you can see where
all items are as well as you also had an
ability where you can change between
either trading orbs tethering more and a
lot of things or being able to increase
the the recovery and armor of everyone
around you for all the kills while
there's tethers now you can actually use
certain exotics and use certain skills
and min/max and get a majority of those
by doing it the right way but if you
look at the Night Stalker build in this
game the fact is that it was either one
you had the rolls that would just make
you slightly invisible for a little bit
longer and then it what it did was it
gave you the smoke grenades that made
you invisible those aren't very useful
right when you're looking in PvP you're
gonna be throwing those so why are you
gonna use those and then they the only
thing that they gave you else was the
increased smoke but it did very little
they didn't have the venom smoke anymore
that made sense or builds I just want to
say one more thing on it I'll be done
with it you know I know Bungie doesn't
like to call destiny and MMO and I and I
get most in there but at the same time I
mean what did the
it like a shared world I just want to
say one quick thing so but the thing is
at the end of the day this is or was a
grindy game this was very MMO like and
it is still you cannot pull yourself out
of that genre
you just can't because if you're trying
to go to the route of just say a shooter
a shared world shooter I think that's
the main problem they tried to take some
of that grind away but you also took
that longevity away yes and and the
thing about mmo's at the end of the day
what keeps people there well it's the
hardcore audience that it's not casual
so when you cater cater to a casual
you're not gonna get them there for the
long haul a goal yes and then that's the
problem that's why millions have left
thanks let me just finish up and I'm
sorry for trap and had a little power
issue but um great points buddy you you
won't find that's why I brought you in
because I think you represent the
informed yet passionate you're not a you
know what I consider destiny hater you
played this game you love part one and
you're upset and it hurts me to hear how
bad Bungie has like dropped a ball for a
person like you to be done because I
know you're a true destiny guy you know
I mean the same thing with Fonz the
whole bit so an addict even after some
respect you know he's a red guy and to
see the raid layers in the state you
know that they are it just hurts him
because that's what we do now I will say
this you know I play war mind
it's definitely substantially better in
my opinion and in our crystal size which
is a very low bar so we're never gonna
go there but at the end of the day I
probably give it a b-minus here's the
thing for an amount of content they're
getting you know the improvements that
they've made are very subtle these are
very small changes what I consider baby
steps for the hardcore to go towards the
ultimate direction that they're trying
to get to you in September September
from what I heard them be we're really
sure you know I put the game now for a
lot of moms to you know I was very
disappointed I
upset that this direction change they
went this over casualisation the
Hawthorn you've talked about it and
nauseam bloody I know you went in my
thing was okay now that the sales have
gone down right because the first year
the sales are great they had the biggest
games 2017 now every subsequent month
they are not even on the destinies not
even on the top 10 of games sold her MPD
like that's that's tremendously low
second player count has dropped
tremendously low look at the trials
numbers look at all ego stats like no
one's the community has moved on let's
be honest the competition you got
fortnight out here right you got for
tonight dropping mini Infinity Gauntlet
bills these free on the day the wall
mine dropped yes
you got you've got all these other
things you got dead you got division
tool coming I know Kings the destiny is
not only the only game in town anymore
you know I'm saying so I didn't think
about think about October funds right
and you got red day you know you got
Call of Duty battlefield finish and all
I'm saying is this is what I like what I
like is now they're forced to bend the
knee they got no choice to listen
because at the end of the day this game
will be done shelter we bond this we do
flatfoot every week this game will be
done you can spend my say it's almost
done now right it's trying to do a
comeback it's on life support all I will
say to you guys is that there's been a
big destiny community summit right and
it to be honest you bloody I thought
this was just all dog and pony show I
thought this is just I'm tryna you know
Craig do for PR thing and I know a lot
of content creators I'll shout out to
you know saying home fall our planes
made Sean the crew all these guys myelin
games the Laura got all that and they
came in with the hard-hitting questions
why did you mess up this game
what was the reasonings what was the
thought process behind the design and
way all these things that you changed it
didn't need to be changed right they
took the feedback they told him those
reasons why I can't say on the NBA
that's cool but then they came back
okay well this is what we got planned
for September guys they told that to the
community the community looked at it and
collectively said no if you release what
you plan on releasing this game is dead
that is not acceptable so at that point
Bungie the devs they came out the room
they took all the feedback they came
back the next day and said okay and took
what you're saying here's what we
proposed instead based on all the
feedback you got standing from the PDP
community to PvE community the raid
community the law community and from
what I was told
from very reliable sources that
September is what everybody wants and is
super excited about now I was told ahead
of time Walmart is not going to change
the game it made subtle changes that
ultimately will lead to September now is
it too late for September it may very
well be you got guys like you who done
with the game they not even trying to
hear it nor trying to pay $40 to
experience a better game I feel there
may be nothing that can save fauns and
bloody that just may be those bridges
may be burnt but I will say this from
very confident sources from people that
I played and also this new moment that
people are talk about that's never been
introduced in destiny that people say is
gonna blow people's mind and from a lore
perspective from here great things attic
it's on you and we move on look at the
end of the day when it comes to this
it's little things they can do to make
it better on me I feel like that's this
expansion was good but there are little
things that they could improve on life
why is that we go for one mission that
we run into the worm in the next mission
we fight it the fight was kind of lame -
it's like they should have been
different phases in the fight at least
yes it's like we literally just he was a
bullet sponge until he died comes to the
raids they dropped the ball every every
time on the raids I I haven't liked the
raid since some wrath of the machines
Leviathan was cool but at the end of the
day you took away that serious yes tone
from destiny you was a game show the
dude was messing with you hold on the
facts
we get to the Osiris like I personally
like the last fight of Osias but
anything up into the last bite was
trapped they could have used that that
never-ending a force they could have
made that into an event they could have
like randomly generated something from
like maybe the of up from year what cuz
that that's pretty much a time machine
to know like if you go and click on it
like it spawns an Odin counter from
destiny one that you can real it like
something to that matter like but they
don't want to do that what they want is
they want to make this game to a bridge
gap where people are satisfied on the
hardcore side but they can bring as much
casual as as possible so they can get
their bank account as big as possible
that was there that was their intent
guess what that didn't work and in one I
realized that that that big bulk of
money that they got last year that was
nice but guess what people aren't
spinning that kind of money at the mercy
like they weren't does anyone because
who's casuals are not gonna go out you
know they will to this to that point but
you got people like you know well
remember when uh what was that expansion
came out and black literally spent a
hundred dollars and got everything in
ten minutes
oh yeah yeah yeah they're not doing it
look we've gone completely over so I
gotta ask the roundtable we have to make
an executive decision because we're
running late I gotta go I know you gotta
go they're just cool addict I appreciate
you stand for the final topics we've got
base consoles micro blame the days gone
arm king I'm put it on you what do you
wanna do you want to do base and then
and the rest or what you want to do yeah
so let's leave Leslie let's bleed them
all in together
alright so so base the quadruple a shoe
base consoles you're topping the
quadruple a studio announced in days
going impressions King start off shut
off your whole point with our base
consoles what you talk the
knows a 4k movies fantastic watch
transformers yesterday I see these
systems these the PlayStation pro and
xbox or 1x and I have the rumblings
talking about new systems right and my
question is when is it time for them to
kill off these base systems like that
the 720 or the night with a 900p xbox
that's holding up pub G or the base
PlayStation and really the base
PlayStation isn't a problem because the
PlayStation Pro is basically the same
exact thing to be honest with you they
never really pushed the power that far
away from the base because the base
PlayStation was pretty much powerful in
itself I don't think they actually
maximizing the power of the Pro and
they're not necessary it's really this
question is basically really for
Microsoft when is it time for them to
kill off their base system and allow the
power that's inside the X to shine
through would you would would y'all be
comfortable for the base system to go to
weigh the dinosaur less farm let's all
jump in because he had to go through the
endure the destiny I'll say this for
Microsoft I mean they already got rid of
the base system right we're talking
about the S here right um so for
Microsoft to me it's it's it's not a
matter of when they do it because again
their whole strategy moving forward is
this iterative thing so they're they're
gonna be happy with all these consoles
coexisting I think at some point right
the X does become the de-facto console
but that's gonna be because of the image
of that machine we're looking at you
know when they're comfortable selling of
that machine at $300 is when you don't
really see the s anymore
and I don't know if that's anytime soon
on the Playstations I I think it goes
back to the same for them I think it's a
it's $200 when they're comfortable
selling that Pro at 200 250
um maybe a packing game or something
like that then we sort of we see them
moving in and not necessarily phasing
out the PlayStation for the base
PlayStation but you'll be selling that
console for about 50 I don't think you
know they've always they've made their
money at the back end of every console
generation selling you know $100 $150
console slims things like that um so we
haven't really seen a redesign of the
ps4 a slim version so that's something
that could be in a pipeline to for
considerably cheaper so to me yet the
the lifespan of the ps4 per se is a base
console is gonna be around for a while I
don't even really going anywhere
lore Fonz what you feel on the base
consoles yeah I don't think they're ever
going anywhere oh well they're not going
anywhere this generation anyway I just
don't think that they're gonna come on I
mean that's that's the majority of the
players out there okay they own these
base consoles and so I don't think
they're gonna get rid of them anytime
soon they'll start to phase them out
once the next generation starts maybe
mid gen start phasing out those older
consoles maybe just keep around the ex
and the pro I don't know but I said as
far as the Pro and the ps4 though like
King said there's not much difference
between those two you know what I'm
saying resolution bump but man the pro
isn't is a good system still man the
base model welcome no doubt Lord bloody
who what do you feel about base model I
mean it's it's kind of a time thing
because especially if you look at
Microsoft there to got rid of the og you
know they transitioned over as the S
being the new the new base that it's the
it's the one that does you know more
than the og did you know offer that for
case scaling and at a very reasonable
price point averaging sometimes around
$180 up - I think it's 250 normally look
at that that's er base and I think that
you know once we start seeing the ex
really drop down to like four hundred
because we see it going on sales for
about 450 - sometimes 400 but once they
set it to about 400 350 and kind of go
lower we're gonna see the the s kind of
phase out and that may not be for
another two years or so fair enough
but but what the PlayStation you know
the slim is a step down from what the
the base ps4 does and and they announce
the slim later and then now they have
the pro like at some point the it's it's
it's shown that they're making and
pushing for the pro to be the de-facto
ps4 so it's about that time to really
kind of phase out the the the base ps4
you know maybe keep the slim if they
want that that optional price point for
a lot of the the the wider audience I
mean I want not want the pro but the
fact that the pro being you know was it
400 and it's off and on sale for 350
almost 300 on on quite often they're
making that the their their their
mainstay and that's their big selling
point you see it in all their
commercials playstation playstation
playstation pro so it's about time for
Sony to really phase out the base maybe
you know like I said keep the slim for
another year or so and then maybe phase
it out but it's obvious that there that
the that the pro is gonna be their main
de facto all around whereas Microsoft is
focusing on using Maddux as as the
family console the entry console and
that the X is you know for for a lot
more the hardcore and and those who
really want the best tech and that we're
gonna see that be there their main state
you know in a few years
ya know I think that you guys are making
all good points to round table I think
we're just in a different space now I
think honestly the way the ecosystem is
these mid generation console refreshes
are it's one of those things that you
know they're trying to move everyone's
trying to educate people moving forward
moving your library for and stuff like
that I do agree with King in one sense
though I mean I think I grew up on a
sense that look that's the majority the
base I don't see them getting rid of it
complete right right now bottom at the
end of the day when the if both
companies apply the philosophy of moving
your library for it at some point the
base will not be able to keep up with
its flat PS 5 and Xbox 2 you know at
some point so there is going to have to
be a hard line in the sand it almost
reminds me of the iterative updates with
iPhone right
I remember having like you know I'm not
an iPhone guy but I like I I touch so
I'm gonna use just for music when I'm at
the gym and at some point it was like
they're talking about four or five years
they upgraded the firmware and
the iPhone 10 or whatever came out my
old iTouch could not compete it could
not do 30 I had to get a new phone I
think at some point there will be a hard
line in the sand a cutoff point which
would probably bring a smile to Lord
Kings face if he wants to phase out face
consoles he's got nothing but love for
premium experiences so I know he'll be
happy about that but that's what I got
on it what you got on out which color
base before you move on no doubts what a
British out TF guard was very patient on
this on one to bring the Microsoft
quadruple a studio Menace article window
sent you right now
and talking about what's going on with
so I'll see the promotion of Matt Bowie
the first party games leave the hiring
of the x2 later studio Daryl Gallagher
and it's setting up in a South Carolina
you know it's kind of like we're sort of
Monica is that you know and they set up
a new studio out there you know in SoCal
and they're talking quads as far as
budget its far raised up making a focal
point and Microsoft trying to make a
splash into resuscitating that first
party so bringing it to the lords let's
thought with funds and then bloody what
do we feel about the quadruple a
announcement in Santa Monica and what
can we expect when you think fonts you
know III think they should start with
getting some triple A's out there
honestly
step in the right direction I think this
is good news and this is something to be
excited about as a gamer in general
people who are nay saying this and and
bad-mouthing it just come on it's not
necessary they're at least putting
together a studio here that's that
should put out some good product that
remains to be seen but a step in the
right direction
yeah my favorite Lord bloody what do you
feel about the quadruple the A's in the
building
I mean it's it's a great thing and I
actually mentioned this back on on grg
and the fact is that one we we know this
was the studio that was being set up for
fir Gallagher because he's right there
in California and that they defined it
as being a very big budget Sudi uh you
know budgets to do with over a hundred
million dollars that means that they're
really trying to put together a big team
to me really big projects these big big
that's what lost oh yeah yeah and and
and what much love to him but the thing
about it too is that think about the
location and what they're doing they're
putting it right in Santa Monica
sanim California Texas some in
Washington and of just on the on the
East Coast are big hotspots for talent
we saw so many big studios in these four
specific areas yes right there in Santa
Monica UC Santa Monica Sony division
that that that did all that we've seen
you know Naughty Dog around and here in
Texas you know you have uh it's it's
studios you have a Bethesda studio you
have a Bioware studio in Austin and
Dallas there's so many big studios and
in California is such a big hotspot from
LA to San Diego and all that area are
big big hot spots for tech companies and
talent for these so them deciding to
want to really put a big studio there
and put someone who with with Gallagher
more than likely being the head of the
studio who brought back really big
franchises in new ways with what he did
with Crystal Dynamics and and tomb
raider alongside Cory ball art you know
he knows what he's doing he can bring
fresh air into either already made IPS
or bring a fresh idea to something new
with a big team this is a great thing
and anyone who's thinking about of it
know this this is a good thing because
this further pushes innovation and
gaming because this helps push Sony to
make either bigger studios or double
down with the studios they have to do
something even better it's a great thing
all the way around shout out to a Doogie
Howser DDS and achat Hayden just
marketing jargon from Marcus off they've
been mostly off Jim scant on anything
intangible he's not feeling the card
with
I got I got what it is though I'll tell
you in a second looks love so it's funny
you mention that cuz i think i think
it's more than marketing jargon I mean
when you when you say core truthfully
right it sounds like a like a marketing
buzz word right but when I think about
Triple A right I think about three
specific pillars that identify those
games for me right I think about I think
about gameplay and mechanics I think
about tech and graphics and I think
about story and I think about these
publishers trying to excel at every
single one of these things to me to make
a cohesive product that is that's
appealing on a while scale that that to
me is what Triple A is right so when you
add that extra a for what Microsoft is
talking about to me from Microsoft that
signifies service mmm I think for me be
sparing them those of you say services
you're scaling them I have a very hard
time believing that Microsoft is gonna
do any sort of game moving forward it
doesn't incorporate some level of
service wait wait so are you saying are
you saying no single I'm not saying no
single player I'm saying they're gonna
incorporate service in some way shape or
form I think I think by what Phyllis
said there's a dedication to bringing
those types of games what we consider
you know the God of War is that the
PlayStation sort of a blueprint I think
that's coming but I think those games
are coming with the addition of some
sort of service model I think that's
Microsoft's Lane I don't see them
abandoning that so when they say
quadruple a that last a for me means
services mmm okay fair enough
shout out to uh Sam Tobin a Chad is
dropping knowledge he's thinking that
the studio is also gonna be in charge of
incubating other new studios he's also
saying that the triple-a I mean the
quadruple they also kind of doubling
down and what bloody was talking about
in reference to um just the amount of
investment you know that's going in you
know as far as that let's get it to the
king you saying this is his Lord and
Savior
oh great mr. rubble I want them to sit
right next to but this is what the last
age stands for me it stands for a
surveillance drone making sure that they
can't be offered a paper because
apparently these dudes got the answers
you don't I don't care how many eight
eight
I don't care how many age you is like
like Lord funds really say yo we got a
body on your crack this is that's the
problem
I don't know who wrote that there think
he made a mistake he probably didn't
understand this was Sony and they said
quadruple a would it would be a pass
though it would be swallowed much easier
for people it is a one a product of this
is true think of this generation can you
name me a game on the Xbox that's that's
an exclusive game that you'll remember
from this gen
I like is I wouldn't say right but it's
right wrong really was a surprise for me
but it's not yeah but that boss kind of
no fuss to even be said don't keep
talking about ten years down the line
you're not gonna remember this Jen of
the xbox for this generation you're not
dropping japonaise gone has released and
some footage game format some green
footage of you information about what's
going on I just want to get brings to
the roundtable have anyone got a chance
to check out any of the footage um let's
give it to uh bloody Oh have you get a
chance to see anything on Days going to
the title interest you it never
interests you I've been very
touch-and-go with with what days gone it
does look interesting I did I when they
first announced it and it looked very
you know World War Z notes of zombies
just chasing the dude you see I'm just
kind of running through that a
lumberyard trying to escape and then
kind of get stuck at the top and they're
just flooding I thought that was an
awesome concept and now they're they're
they still have some of that but you
know they're really going down into the
story of the main character and oh you
know I want some of the footage it looks
it looks good it does still definitely
show us Falls I dunno was it was an
alpha footage you know the the framerate
and all that kind of stuff I wasn't too
bothered about I want to see more of the
direction and and kind of get more out
of what they're gonna do with it it does
it does hold my attention right now
right it is also gonna be comparing and
and fighting with that that you know
zombie aspect
with World War Z having been being made
an official game having that same kind
of style zombies but as they're called I
believe they're called freaker's and
there's going which is one of those
things that I'm just like alright then
but you know you know it is gonna be you
know a weird spot but you know people
say that they're tired of of zombies but
you know each each game sometimes oh
yeah it keeps coming out but I mean
zombies are one of those things that are
kind of you know iconic and each kind of
does them differently
you know left for dead did them very
well and a lot of people remember left
for dead say the caves doing it in a
very different manner of which did you
feel the timing of their days guys
announcement was kind of interesting
once the state of the cave I'm gonna I'm
going to keep an eye on days gone and
see see when they do it that I believe
that's one of the games that they are
stayed in the bigger show off at e3 so
we're all gonna get to see it live no no
see see how that goes from there you
know don't blow Fonzarelli what days
gone any interest I know you're a samba
guy that that day is gone our footage
did no justice you know it didn't didn't
do anything for me it actually made me
think you know why they even show this
stuff wow this is alpha footage like
Point C I've never understood why they
want to put like their worst foot
forward these devs sometimes they'll be
really really old and why would you do
that to me it's it does a disservice to
your product and um I just thought it
didn't look well polished at all and and
it had some you know jank to it here and
there and the game itself I'm still not
hooked on this game I mean there's
something that's - it's freezed much
last of us but without little part in
the
there and so and I think that's why they
released his sort of early you know
anyway because they know I'd be three
stacked up against the Last of Us - it's
not going to do well at all it wasn't
mentioned as part of the four I thought
that was interesting and it won't me I
don't think it's gonna be a main focus
and that's the reason why they like Game
Informer take aid here in this forest
it's not a zombie genre for me it's
still state of decay all the world that
list the survivalist aspect the RPG
elements it's got everything going for
it mm-hmm no doubt loss off days going
on very curious you're the single player
suffrage experience I usually try not to
watch a lot of footage of these games
beforehand especially not an hour of
footage but I did watch this because I
sort of feel the same way that France
does and Knox does where's my god what
is this game what is it it fits that
Sony mold perfectly from an aesthetic
point of view but where's the heart of
this game right and after seeing that's
what is it just feels like sort of an
amalgam of gameplay systems from games
like state of decay Oh The Last of Us
even water cry you know like with the
crafting and the survival aspects of it
the open-world aspects of it like it
it's questioned how open the world
really is something that I saw was like
well you're on the motorcycle they never
showed the motorcycle go off-road the
motorcycle was always on an actual Road
and they've always made sure that when
you walked off to the side you were
walking you weren't actually riding you
can't couldn't ride the bike into the
middle of the forest to do whatever you
want it so it seems it seems like it's a
limited open world I don't think they
never see right it's right what it's
linear wide right or you can do certain
stuff but they're claiming it's an open
world right um what are the stuff like
the there's only one writer for the game
right so it means like the that the
stories the vision for the story is
unified right but it also seen what the
characters felt a little cookie
I like the interactions between deacon
which is the best porn name ever Deacon
st. John
I like the interactions between him and
his friend like about to go buy a game
right now with deacon st. James the
interactions between the two main
characters seem cool they seem they seem
like very natural but the writing seems
a little trophy you know this guy's
angry his wife is dead this and the
other it also seems like they they
borrowed a lot of stuff from like
horizon zero dawn like the crafting
stuff exactly
all of the items it's just to me it's a
matter of how is this game gonna differ
eight differentiate it so from those
other games I think some of these
developers you know they have their own
interpretations of open world because we
have an open world you know it's not
[Music]
begin with that aren't days gone we
started check out t icgn tomorrow at
noon look at it looks like you have
something cooking on that article
oh look King let's wrap this thing my
whole let you know I didn't know watch
any of this footage I don't do that
Sony experiences are exactly what they
are this is what I was talking about
before when I say I don't believe Gears
of War was actually gets a war I
actually believe it was another game and
they just slapped years old on top of it
through the mythos they had this stuff
set up properly it could have been
easily days gone could add zombies
cradle zombies whatever I just feel
that being that this game doesn't have a
big name attached to it people feel like
oh you know what is it about what's the
heart of the game uh you know that was
crazy when you said that I wanted to
know the heart of the game I don't care
about the heart of the game the game
looks good I'm gonna purchase it because
Sony said so that's a fact it's a new
name I'm gonna test it um let's see what
it does if it pans out the pans out if
it doesn't it doesn't but I have seen so
far in this generation and last
generation Sony has taken these one play
experiences and flesh them out for me I
gotta say though the reason why you know
me and solve I think said the same thing
about you know no heart to this game so
far is because in those other games that
Sony has put out they've grabbed us to
some degree with these stories in these
trailers in the very beginning map and
in this one has not grabbed me at all
yet but the heart but but the issue is
Sony games with these story narrative
games that's what they rely on most is
these story focused games and and if we
don't see that story panning out you
know the you know purchasing day one
like when it comes to when it comes to
Sony there's a few things that are
impressive here right they've let Bend
work on this game for god knows how long
right they've been working on this since
after goals in the base so they're gonna
let them take the time to make the game
what they want it to be and even if the
first outing of this game isn't a God of
War kind of 10 or whatever they're gonna
probably allow them to make another one
and this is what this
been the mo for years already dick with
people as to what regardless to what I
see this being the start of something
regardless of how the first one pans out
no though i'ma finish it up because
Sinister's hitting us with the wrap it
up I've had medium to medium interest in
these monsters we saw out the Attic we
went you know behind C been studio and
you know got a chance to see some behind
the scenes on it and it was cool you
know looks cool um you know I agree with
King I did kind of thought the zombie
horde mechanic was interesting you know
I just like the dynamic between using
the Horde against enemies as well but
that was but that's kind of interesting
you know am I saying is the most unique
thing I've ever seen no I guess for me
it's playing I'm a huge Sons of Anarchy
fan so for whatever reason Deacon is the
the character at home or Maz we had a
whole do what's his name from the leader
[Laughter]
so like I said what I saw recently was
it ending wowing oh my god never seen
before no and I do agree with Fonz
though in the sense that because it's
that narrative driven type game it needs
to kind of meet that level and
unfortunately because the games like are
war right now the bar is so high so now
we kind of look at everything with the
cry now with the solder like you know
you know how's your story gonna be
though you know because we just
experienced yes it's too familiar to the
state of decay I mean not state last of
us it's too familiar to that we did
answer that the Barney Ross question
Victor we had um um a mistake writers
comment but not are you what you say in
our phones you know and
time will tell we will see but that's
what we got let's wrap this thing up and
a poll question do Dow Jones get it so a
poll question when Leakes this is
inspired J Fonzarelli
we're leaks from credible sources are
revealed prior to e3 how does this
impact your view of the ìiî conferences
when they go live the choices are a love
it I want to know all the leaks all the
plans B hate it ruins my e3 experience
or see you make a Sony eat me flames and
still pleasure to have you on this
Mother's Day we want extra guys to be in
the realm long overdue law runs whether
I can define people function first of
all thank you for coming through man oh
dude my pleasure man any time you guys
want me I'm like cool Sunday mornings
easy for me to get here nice appreciate
it you can find me at J Fonzarelli on
YouTube and Twitter on YouTube it's J
then space Fonzarelli for some reason it
just that's the way yeah it's hard
finding you you to I had to put that
space base I papa
but anyway and other than that you can
find me an RDX on Tuesdays 5 8 p.m.
Eastern Time you know so I'm no longer
on the saltiest podcast but follow them
Thursdays on saltiest gaming's channel
they do a great podcast that absolutely
sounds an assault irrelevant all the
crew you know say I love that podcast
great podcast no doubt in first what
that also Lord the fans thank you so
much for indulging us in combats but he
had a few yeah baby wanted to hate isn't
chat that way behind the scenes and I
believe that they was planted in the
crowd that was paid
doesn't know yeah but I always
appreciate you yeah I think that
somebody in the chat wants an outro by
captain neutral oh yes let's get captain
neutral come on I am captain neutral
message any logical gamers taking refuge
among the toxicity of social media we
are here good use of the Xbox voice
changer able to play games and not be
harassed before once again the combat
sports was lit time stance will go up
later for people who even watch it live
you have an issue
Lord bloody knuckles making his debut in
the room with that passionate oh my like
me yeah me my feelings I'm like wait a
minute but he's kind of saying the right
things
love buddy but absolute pleasure wicked
of fine people find you then everyone
can find me on Twitter at bloody
knuckles the O's are zeros the EES are
threes of course they could find us on
my show every Saturday this which
podcast yes you know what the set is
what time plug it sir go on 2:30
Central's sometimes we go a little bit
later depending on our guest looking out
for it and especially maybe yesterday's
episode check it out we did go into it
there was some good stuff but two weeks
ago you have to see that our spoiler
test honest looking we did three and a
half hours of telling you but the thing
is we didn't even know it went three to
half hours we're just going off and he
David came out there with us we had the
homie
Jamie Moran you he was on there with
Moran was that we had 108 dragons TV
with us for a little bit it was a good
it was a good show just real passion it
was actually one of our highest viewed
videos hitting over a hundred so please
check it out we're closing in on a
hundred subs oh that man out man yeah
love what you're doing out here man
thanks I'm so glad you reached out
cognate like I said ever since i sat
with with you and King David on on
saltiest gaming you know love the guys I
started trying to catch in when I can
you heard me going about destiny so I
you know one thing about me in the
Lord's like even when people disagree
with me or we have different viewpoints
I respect educated opinions and one
thing is I always turned out like this
guys passionate he knows what he's
talking about though and it's great to
have those debates and that's one thing
we welcome in the Lord's but in the
realm you know even if we are different
size and offense it's the company and
talking to understand perspective and
that's definitely my appreciation I had
to have you on I wore my kind it was
gonna be late I know and I appreciate
that because that's what I've always
said is it doesn't matter any of the
console were nonsense we we clown around
with each other but the thing is at the
end of the day we're all gamers you know
family we're a community we have to get
past that if we want gaming to grow and
continuing you have to have discussions
you can't go bitch-ass on any side you
have to be able to talk openly and see
the the good and bad on both sides
absolutely man that's why you need it in
the realm and like what you're doing man
Lord rap you're late you're just coming
in good stuff but yeah absolutely
appreciate it man absolutely fantastic
Lord saw what I had to go I know you had
Mother's Day going on Lord saw where can
you find people not find you bloody
necks and fawns man you guys are
fantastic I ask ask the Cognito this
morning who's gonna be your honey
[Laughter]
you cannot find me at the TT on Twitter
and being sovereign on PSN and Xbox Live
hopefully this week it's been two weeks
since I've been able to touch God of War
I've been on the same Valkyrie fight for
two weeks trying to get some got a war
in so we'll see if that happens
no doubt no change ringing that energy
that come loose what's energy shoutout
to the special guys J Fonzarelli and
bloody knuckles let me tell you
something I had my cake in a tattoo
today
because with the combat sports I'm so
happy that he sought a loan match and go
fight and I definitely saw some of the
UFC so I love when he comes through and
I link them in every tweet that I put
out that has anything to do with combat
sports because his love for combat
sports shines thank you for saying thank
you Fanny because law firms well I'm
gonna be honest with you like you
inspired us to continue to do it because
we would kind of ensure we you know
something that we always thought hey I
love listening to Sparta this combat
sports talk so you know when you guys
were doing I was surprised when I first
heard you guys doing that I was like yes
finally I get to hear somebody that that
knows what they're talking about and
it's fun and engaging it's it's awesome
which is the facts and and like I said
for the community that loves it we
really appreciate for those who aren't
offense on it we appreciate you
respecting the time stamps washes over
my back because let me tell you
something if you know nothing about
combat sports you understand my
enthusiasm if you can ride with me all
the way through you're definitely ride
to the end check this out though bloody
knuckles I'm going to tell you something
you kind of scared me with the white
hand gloves that you had when you got
my son's I felt the passion I felt like
I felt it that day on the smash podcast
I'm gonna tell you right now brother
like I told you before anytime you want
me there I'm there I love everything
about the show today it was fantastic
you guys can catch me everywhere you
know where it is but I'm going to tell
you those t-shirts is going to be too
weak oh then I'm going to put up the
link so everybody can figure I know
you're hitting me and my dance is going
crazy
the shirts will be out we'll be five
colors and we will have those sizes for
the big plus guys ladies of the round
the models of the room I want that when
we all meet up and eat laughs right we
will be out the other late move font I
do not that fossil we need to see you do
realness has been spread in the room
you'll shout out to the chat today
absolutely fantastic so much fun
shopping Brad oh so many faces and much
appreciated again for those who are
interested in the destiny scene flash
point number 14 but my man advances on
the eve of the war mine it was up you
can talk about we talk about that and
get into our last when a deeper dive
just stay away from bloody you know hate
on us appreciated you know child
everyone you know and also shot the
little caveat so the audio will be up
with timestamps later on today and make
sure you hit the like subscribe to all
the inner circle yeah outlets multiverse
will be tomorrow Sam Tober has an
article going up on tcid icgn calm also
shout out to the affiliate wrap on for
guys recorders nlg all our breath breath
Hren under the ticke banner much
appreciate it and we're gonna have a
very very special show next week
we're gonna start our prediction series
and Nintendo will be up so it is
interesting so yeah make sure you in its
been pocket guess it's gonna be like a
little switch gang mob boss kind of fear
that's what we want so please do
everybody enjoy your mother day anybody
has anything so before we get out of
here yeah get your friend codes out for
next week check our channel because we
have videos that we're putting up we're
trying to expand naturally just made two
going in about venom so if you're
looking at that you want to see those as
well as I'm actually gonna be posting up
anime reviews and stuff like that you
come on come on bloody knuckles smash
podcast look it up come on no doubt
alright now nope we ending it everyone
enjoyed this funny and happy Mother's
Day